foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
reservation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just blocked yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in weight
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon him
they both know this is a draw there's
the handshake it is a split point which
means got a pomshi keeps his one point
advantage in this match
dingley Wren knows firsthand what the
end of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame the path to come back
is getting narrow now with just three
games he will have to take maximum risk
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
foreign
world championship match we are in cool
Astana but the temperatures are rising
inside the halls of the Saint Regis
Hotel and that is where the action
happens we will take you live to the
playing arena in moments from now yeah
and ding lyrin will arrive it is the
final phase of the world championship
match and we are expecting a fiery game
12. I am International Master Tanya
sachdev alongside Michael commentators
and good friends Grandmaster Robert Hess
and super Grandmaster Fabiano caruana
welcome guys the world championship
match resumes after the rest day and now
Chad got some sleep we as commentators
got some sleep Fabi you've been on this
stage at this point are the players
getting any state any sleep
I hope they're getting some sleep
they're certainly going to need the
energy today and coming into the final
super crucial games they're gonna need
all the rest that they can get uh to
have the energy to potentially win this
world championship
Robert what's that been like for you
Sleepless in New York calling the chess
action is that the American dream
well no sleep for the weary thankfully I
have leftover preparation for the 2021
World Championship I may not been
playing but Fabiano and I were up at the
crack of dawn every single morning and
so I'm ready I hope dingley Ren is ready
because he cannot be sleepy at the board
today yeah he needs to be well time is
running out just three games remain Dean
needs to find his chances to equalize
the match saw five decisive results in
the first half an explosive start it was
fire on board right from the opening
phase big surprises in the opening Big
Time scrying Booth big risks but going
into the second half after four
back-to-back victories that we saw well
it's been a very stable Affair the
players have been playing with caution
they have been playing solid chess
confident draw draws there and it has
coincided with a rumored for tension
preparation League of training games
Hikaru Nakamura said it is an
unprecedented World Championship prep
League well has the last four draws Fabi
bought that time for Team ding to come
up with fresh opening ideas what was
that the strategy with the cautious
approach that we saw from ding
I think that we've seen with ding's
recent white approaches and he's he's
trying to feel yawn out and you know
trying to feel aware there might be some
weakness in the repertoire but it
generally feels like he has run out of
ideas and he kind of alluded to that a
little bit in the press conference where
he said that he will use the rest day to
search for new ideas
and that suggests that the repertoire
that was built up over the months and
months of preparation before the match
has run out that's normal in a very long
match here you can't create a million
opening ideas with the white pieces or
with the black pieces at some point they
run out and I I think near the end of
the match both players have started to
slow down a bit with their opening
approach also we saw Yan playing rather
steady quiet
slightly poisonous lines but nothing
super super uh direct or threatening in
the last few games
and Daily Bread has been open honest
respectful emotional during those
post-game press conferences he's going
to need to have the game be open he's
gonna have to leave his emotions out
there on the board today he's going to
have to be vicious no more respect for
his opponent because dingley Wren needs
a win and he needs it now there are only
three games remaining in this match
thing is running out of time he is
running out of games to make that
comeback for Jan napomnushi his Ultimate
Dream is just three games away he
doesn't need to win a game he just needs
to make sure that he doesn't lose one
Robert Jan's got to be feeling the
nerves as well at this point he
certainly must because it's a childhood
dream for him hopefully about to come
true it's only three games away he can
see that he can see the glory he can see
that prize you can see the title that he
has wanted his whole life so yeah for
Jana palmchi I'm not sure how he was
able to get any sleep either and he's
going to need to be well rested because
dingly Ren is going to come punching
today
so close yet so far for Yan and Katie
after game 11 did ask him if indeed the
hardest part of the match was behind him
and Yan responded in disbelief
you got to be kidding no
it's like it's
free games and like
um I I should I should give it all yeah
to
uh to to do the job let's say so but uh
of course like it's
nothing like anything like
uh like it's over obviously not it's
pretty
pretty much in clear match I think of
course I would try my best in the last
three games
also tomorrow will be will be addressed
day I have more time to prepare some
extra ideas
the job isn't over he's still got what
to do but it essentially will be over if
he can get one more win in and these are
the odds that the chesscom stats team
gives Yan based on the result of today's
Big Game 12 game starts with the black
pieces if he wins it will essentially
mean match over it says 98 percent I
wouldn't be surprised if it's at 99.9
for that in that scenario impossible for
ding to make a comeback from a two-point
deficit with for Yan a draw is also a
great result with the black pieces the
big question Fabi for Yan's theme will
be to figure out where will ding try to
poke and prod out of the opening how in
a world championship match can Team Yan
and the team of seconds try to figure
that out
well I think the more interesting
question is is for ding in fact because
for yawn it's it's I think going to be
pretty standard uh going to the game
with the black pieces he is going to try
to play normal repertoire
um what he prepared before the match
he's not going to change anything up
because changes take a lot of nervous
energy and a lot of work and you don't
want to do that at the moment when I'm
sure both players are super super tired
and they want to preserve energy as much
as possible for ding it's more a
question of where can I search for new
ideas and I think generally speaking you
don't want to go into territory where
you don't know where your opponent might
be going so he has information on what
Jan wants to do in the English he has
information on what he almost wants to
do with the names of Indian those are
the places where I would be searching
for ideas because at least you can kind
of guess where your opponent will be
trying to go that would be my guess one
of those two openings and I'm really
thinking we might see another reverse
Sicilian today but who knows at this
stage in the match
all options are on the table
to go for it and
creation there he has to create his
chances that's for sure team Yan has to
take that solid approach and Robert Fabi
is alluding to a 1c4 start I want to ask
you apart from the opening phase what's
the one thing that you'd like to see
from ding today
I would like to see him show no fear of
course the opening will play a part in
that but I also think that back in game
seven and then in game eight he was
nervous about the clock and he was
looking at the clock regularly making
sure that he didn't get into too much
time trouble so I want to see ding just
be loose I want him to be able to play a
game where it's must win territory
starting to feel that way but as he
himself said that he won the final game
of the candidates over Hikaru Nakamura
to earn his right to this world
championship so he's proven than the
very last game Against All Odds he can
get that dub so I think that for dingley
Ren I want to see him come out fighting
not make a peaceful solid draw he really
needs to throw everything but the
kitchen sink at Yana Palmer Street today
has to do
to do for him but time is running out it
is one of his final two whites today the
last time he won a game in this match
was back in game six and while we saw a
lot of back and forth and punches being
traded by both these players in the
first half we see an extremely high
accuracy rate there in the second half
of the match and to me it looks like
while chess if played perfectly draw is
a natural conclusion is that what we saw
happen Robert there in the last four
games where we witnessed four draws I'll
be fighting once yeah because you'll see
a bunch of games where the percentage is
under 90 and that makes sense because
one side has to make a mistake in order
for the other to win and game eight that
was a draw but actually dingley Ren
could have won that with proper
execution when he could have taken a
rook so I think that the last few games
we've seen that Elite super Grand Master
chess that we all know and sometimes
don't love because there are a lot of
draws but you can hardly fault the
players because they're really not
faulting at all
and there we see dingler has arrived
some anti-cheating measures of fide with
the international Arbiter gopa Kumar are
in order and they're going on big
burning question Fabi will Yan return
with the pink shirt
well it's been working from the last few
games he's been making solid draws and
that's what he needs at this stage in
the match as he said you know he won't
mind a draw with black pieces at all
getting closer to the to the finish line
and I think for ding it's maybe already
close to a must win game but he still
has to straddle that line between I
really want to win this game but I have
to avoid a loss at all costs while if
you're in a pure must win you can just
throw caution to the wins because it
doesn't matter at that point he's still
at that at that point where he can't
lose and although he wants to win still
a draw would keep it more or less within
that Striking Distance but a losses as
you said uh turning into a pretty much
desperate practically hopeless situation
it's such a tightrope to walk and where
you have to take this calculated risk
you know you have to create your chances
you have to get your opponent into
complication give him the chances to go
wrong but in that well in that deep dark
Forest of Mikhail tal where two plus two
is equal to five it can indeed backfire
for either of the two players and we see
yeah he does indeed return with the pink
shirt it's been working great for him
all he needs to do is to make sure that
things are kept under control with the
black pieces Robert for ding is it time
to start playing every single game like
his last I like what Fabiana was just
saying there that for ding he really
wants to win but he cannot afford a loss
and I'm thinking about this from Beyond
the Palm she's perspective and not just
because he would go full Damien from
Mean Girls I want my pink shirt back if
someone took it away from him he is
doing what works well for him that
salmon colored shirt has worked to
Perfection he has not lost while wearing
it so he's got to keep keep rocking it
and I think for dingly run yeah he is
going to just go into that Forest he's
going to try to divert yawn into past
that are not so known to him but easier
said than done when Yonder Palm she's
coming off not just two Kindred
victories but it's his second World
Chess Championship and he is extremely
well prepared
Game 12 coming up
decisive result will ding push too far
will he be the one who might backfire
too now remember if ding loses at this
point it will be match over he has to
make sure that he gets his chances but
in a way that he can also keep things
under control he does have one more
white and it will come in that final
game 14 while the players are getting
ready to step into the playing Arena we
still see the chairs are empty it will
be arriving any moment taking off those
jackets handshakes will happen and once
again the big question will be where has
team ding found the chances to poke and
to prod Yan out of the opening now Fabi
we saw in uh in the interview where in
fact ding said that he wants to look for
these fresh ideas you're suggesting a
1c4 Robert I'm gonna predict the 1d4
what's your prediction for move one well
I think I would be a bit silly not to
just latch on to what Bobby said I mean
that guy's played a world championship
match back in 2018 he's got a lead
preparation so what he would do against
the Underpants I think maybe dingley
wrench should follow his advice C4 I was
gonna say I might actually change my
prediction
I was thinking of doing that right
before you said that and now I'm like I
don't want to leave you you know you
know lying in the dirt alone with the C4
prediction but I really like a nimzo
it's it's kind of speaking to me now
with E3 some sort of Rubenstein maybe
with A3
uh some Echoes of what we saw in that
last game where ding had super huge
chances in the eighth game that would be
exciting A zamish variation possibly
maybe an F3 nimzo there's a lot of
a lot of Rich directions to turn to in
the nimzo so Tanya I also predict the
nimzo maybe a Samus variation uh the
nimso seems about right so that's my
prediction for today one second boys I'm
the one who said one D4 start with
I love how Abby Robert wanted to follow
your 1c4 and now you say one D4 well
Robert seems to agree Chad what do you
think well I will think finest chances
will it be 1c4 1d4 or will it be
something completely random something
that we haven't seen so far now in game
four the first game that the England won
it was indeed the English opening game
six which didn't learn what was the
never seen before at the world
championship match the London opening so
we might see something uh that we have
no idea what it will be but we will find
out in just a few moments we see Yan
haponishi has arrived he's ready to go
what has his team expected from ding is
also the big question uh Fabi we saw Yan
shut down game 11. he was disappointed
with not being able to create too many
chances but it really was his own
decision to trade off the pieces to go
into the end game that also comes from a
place of really conserving energy and
stamina at this stage of the match how
important is that for the players
well I really do feel like that was a
bad decision by him though despite the
match situation despite you know how
he's up in the match and and in a vacuum
of course draw with white or black is
one step closer but I was looking at
that game afterwards analyzing it a bit
and it was really really unpleasant and
it was super safe also for for white if
he had played that Queenie 2 move that
we were talking about it was a safe
basically a free roll as uh as I think
dubov put it uh you know white was
playing
uh for for no risk and and with good
chances of potentially getting a serious
advantage and he looked disappointed he
also looked a bit tired to me in the
post game press conference I think that
um he still needs to keep his psychology
at a good level if if he lets that slip
if he's trying to like
you know avoid calculation or avoid
difficult decisions I could really come
back
uh to bite him you know it's as as Jan
said himself it's still the match is
fully on there's it's not going to be an
easy road to the Finish Line whether he
wins or not it's it's still a huge
battle I mean these guys are are
Gladiators and uh and they're gonna be
fighting to their last breath you know
if if ding needs to win in that final
game
uh he's going to fight until the bear
King so Eon still needs to keep his his
psychology fully there he has to keep
his head in the match and decisions like
that one they're a little bit concerning
from that point of view
it's gonna be a spectacular game to all
of is what I'm predicting we're also
getting some chat predictions in on
ding's first move and while Chad thinks
it's gonna be one E4 I would be
absolutely shocked to see that happen
it's not something that we see very
often from Ding and 32 saying 1d4 I
think that has something to do with
Robert and Fabi switching sides at some
point but also the English opening at 20
so a big question there for dingler and
we've been talking about Yan's decision
for game 11 yes but how hard is it for
ding as well to deal with the fact that
this game this match could have been
equalized in game eight itself where he
had the option to actually pick up the
rook and the match on the spot and
that's definitely something that's way
more haunting than anything uh that Yan
has been able to create with the white
pieces Robert yeah it's a great point I
think that for dingley Wren people say
oh his losses must be the brutal part of
the match no game eight that was a
missed opportunity
missed opportunity and we see at least
the first moves have happened the guest
plays the move with the Queen spawn
opening 1d4 on the board ding is going
to put that pawn right back before he
shows us what is his preparation where
indeed does he want to test Jana Pam
Nashi it's not just going to be about
the opening phase tabi as you mentioned
no matter what position we get it very
well could be a battle that comes down
to a King versus King position yeah
certainly but I think we will see the
move deep because it looked like ding
was gesturing to like make that move so
it looked like it wasn't the uh the
guest's choice so much as ding telling
him I want to play D4 so I think we may
see him imzzo which is an exciting uh
Prospect because the names was a really
fighting opening but only if white
doesn't move that Queen to C2 then it's
like super Josh but we'll see in a
second whether he wants to play D4 or
not
it's gonna happen I have a feeling 1d4
commanding
do this do this with the chat do it for
the commentators well he did get a great
position out of the nimzo E3 A3 line
Fabby something that is your a specialty
is it as well and there we have it
Robert 1d4 on the board you're welcome I
called it what do you mean you're
welcome I'm the one who said oh D4 maybe
a nimzo maybe a Samus you can rewind the
tape and oh well
no names are we going to see a London
are we gonna to see the bishop on F4 and
move three no the London would be an
awful choice for dink oh don't play oh
my God
on the edge of my seat here not Bishop
F4 here that's gonna be an absolute
shocker ding slowing down Robert what
are the chances of a London here I don't
think we'll see the London just because
he's played it before and E3 oh my
goodness he is playing a quiet line
this is uh known as the Cole right
and yeah I was I was kind of thinking
that this could when he was like
hesitating I was thinking he could play
G3 he once played this against me and
it's sort of
kind of pseudo uh Catalan approach but
E3 a favorite of Vladimir kramnik he was
he was playing like this a lot in like
2017. of course it's it's a system
that's as old as the Hills
and
you can play C5 here I mean you well
basically the world is is Black's oyster
here because you can play what you want
uh C5 is super likely I would I would
think
and yeah we're seeing a sort of quiet
game but it's a good place to get a
fight so I don't dislike this this
decision from
from ding because yeah it's one of those
kind of positional systems if black
doesn't remember it super well
um
I don't know what like main move is here
my D2
I think that white also had like a lot
of different approaches
and now
Knight to C6 looks like the most logical
move
and we'll at some point probably see
wide play with the development of B3
Bishop to B2 Bishop to D3 post tonight
on E5 this is like standard stuff right
uh for example I think
you know we could make a few moves like
Knight to C6 E3 in a Blitz game you know
just just like playing them
automatically or even a bullet game E6
Bishop B2 Bishop to D6 at some point
white puts the Knight on E5 and tries to
create an attack on the king side with
F4 Rook to F3 and all those standard
attacking moves and for uh
for our viewers in the chat I actually
think this is a great opening for for
all levels to play because if you know
it well you can just completely blow
your opponent off the board with with
the King side attack
so it looks quiet but it has that
long-term poison
and Bobby I want to make a quick point
that you're saying Knight C6 here and
that does sacrifice a pawn now before
this Knight went out to D2 Queen A5
would have been a check to win that pawn
right back on the spot and Jan says I
don't even want to give you the
opportunity to take on C5 and he takes
on D4 so I was actually just thinking
that for Jana palmchi when you just need
a draw you're kind of in this weird
territory where you have some results
oriented thinking you don't want to
allow dingly rent to muddy the waters
let's just trade pawns now he could play
Knight C6 if he wants that didn't cost
black anything to trade in the center
sometimes you want to keep the tension
often we do but I think this was a good
decision to kind of minimize the risk
listen to our opening Choice by ding it
feels like he's saying I don't want to
get into any theoretical battles any
theoretical lines I just want a game I
just want a position where we have a lot
of pieces on the board a lot of Pawns
and it's going to be a long fight what
ding seems to be signaling her is that
it's not going to be about the opening
but more about the middle game and the
end game phase of the opening and what
you mentioned Robert about Yan taking a
decision based on the Mad situation a
result-oriented decision on the board
sometimes that could lead to a player
not making the most Optimum choice on
the board because your psychology is so
dependent on trying to shut down the
game Fabi do you see that as a factor as
a challenge for for ding for Jan sorry
yeah it definitely potentially could be
uh as as we mentioned before like
psychology will play a huge role in this
in this match coming into the final
games it's not just going to be about
Chess it's also going to be about nerves
and is your mindset is your mind in the
right place and all those other factors
that you know we think about Chess isn't
just the moves but of course it's it's
about
you know it's about everything it's not
just about moves it's about how you feel
physically how you're approach mentally
the psychology behind it everything is
is an important factor
but in terms of the pure opening at this
point I think it's too early to say it
where are these guys minds are at
um
but we do know that Jan has come with a
rare approach
Queen C7 not a move which comes to mind
immediately
and
obviously honest prepared because he
played it very quickly and it's
it's not a usual move it's not like what
you would first think of you think okay
I get my Knights to Center develop my
Bishop out and you know standard Knight
C6 Bishop to F5 or G4 that sort of stuff
so why Queen C7
first I would guess he doesn't want to
play an ic6 here
so what is the point of this
it kind of looks like an exchange
caracon right so we can get this type of
position via the carocon but the queen I
see often goes to C7 in those variations
I'm not sure what is gained but I do
want to quickly take a step back and go
back a couple moves because I think it's
instructive to our viewers the point
that we were making in the early stage
if we could bring up an analysis board
that after this Knight d2 move uh black
with C5 if you took on C5 black can
regain the pawn with this check over
here right away so the point I had made
earlier was after Knight D2 now that's
no longer checks if black could start
with Knight C6 white can take this Pawn
on C5 and if you play Queen A5 this can
get black into an iffy situation you
play A3 saying have that pawn and then
you quickly play B4 and you see the
evaluation going up in White's favor
with rapid development black is going to
be lagging behind because white puts the
bishop on B2 takes this diagonal can
strike with C4 gaining space in addition
to time so I just wanted to a highlight
that in that variation white is Robert
go ahead sorry sorry to interrupt but in
case of E6 here is is black regaining
the pawn in a very
um comfortable way
I was wondering that
yeah the only way to defend it is not to
be three right I guess this is probably
the variation
that uh that you were thinking of but
after Knight to E4
I guess we get the pawn back right quite
comfortably and
I wonder if this exchange of the Central
Pawn for the C Pawn is going to lead to
an adventure for it or if it's just
going to lead to quite easy quality for
black
now I was wondering the same thing I was
like does why have C4 here maybe
training queens and we know that dingley
Ren he can make the most of small
advantages he is a kind of a maximalist
in that sense where he gets this tiny
Edge and he puts pressure like he did
against Fabiano you're Fabiano in the
final round of the uh candidate so I was
just thinking maybe he's just trying to
take yon out of preparation and try to
get a more comfortable position for
himself but you're right that black
would regain this Pawn right away and
maybe it's not really so much of an
opening Advantage but a decision based
in Comfort zones
yeah it's well
I I think that that was definitely a
possibility after Knight to C6 but we're
seeing a totally different type of
position in fact the same structure that
we saw in that London game which uh ding
eventually won a very important game
frame of course different material
balance there are the darts where
Bishops were exchanged
here it's hard to see how those dark
Spirit Bishops would be exchanged in the
near future but the same exact Carl's
Bad sort of structure
and we see Ian having his first sink
after the move C3 well often in these
positions uh Black's light squared
Bishop wants to arrive on that F5 square
and he need to decide if he wants to do
that at the moment he could also think
about developing the queen side Knight
to C6 but then that would give the
additional option today to actually go
with his own Bishop to D3 taking control
of the diagonal and then black is left
with not such great options for a square
for the C8 Bishop but on the other hand
a move like Bishop F5 Yan needs to be
thinking about moves like Knight to H4
hitting that Bishop in return so Yan
contemplating all these decisions while
you guys were analyzing this these lines
about giving up the pawn on C5 I was
thinking about what has been going on in
the match so far every time ding has
played an opening that of course Yan has
an idea about or prep about but wasn't
perhaps expecting it on that particular
day we've seen him make very practical
choices on the board when it was the
French ding with the black pieces
playing the French Yan did go for the
tarash variation instead of the more
topical win of air or the E5 Advance
which would ensue a lot of complications
and that's exactly the approach that
we're seeing with Jan with the black
pieces today as well not sacrificing the
pawn not going for those imbalance
position but taking a quick decision to
grab on D4 to simplify the center
throughout the match I want to ask both
of you and I'll start with Fabi has it
seemed to you that Yan perhaps has been
the player better prepared in the
opening despite ding being the one
coming up with the surprises
I think that Jana has chosen a very
pragmatic approach to the openings which
is that he plays quite positional uh
relatively solid systems you know he's
for example this like you know we
mentioned black could have played Knight
C6 inviting D takes C5 instead he's
going or just standard sort of Carlsbad
structures
also against London he was playing the
most positional system where he takes on
D4 he doesn't you could try to grab a
Pawn on B2 in the London you can play
some crazy variations that we were
talking about
um
but he's he's playing super super solid
uh positional approaches Queen C7 I
still don't like know the subtlety
behind this move I'm trying to
understand it but it's not really coming
to mind why Queen z7 overnight C6
but I'm sure that there is some reason
why why you might play Queen C7 first
and yeah as as you mentioned here Bishop
to F5 really comes to mind as the most
natural move you stop Bishop D3 if
Knight H4 you can just play Bishop's G4
looks pretty reasonable to uh hit that
Queen game Tempo on the queen on D1
and the question is yeah does he want to
play Bishop 5 does he want to play
Knight C6
I would I would think about it Bishop 5
first is the most logical move
looks pretty logical to me I mean it
seems like black has several options and
for young he's just trying to be
accurate here uh Knight C6 sometimes you
meet that with Bishop to B5 pinning that
Knight maybe that's why he started with
Queen C7 just to give that Knight an
extra Defender it's hard to really
describe sometimes the different move
orders it seems like they all lead to
the same place but every single move
allows something from your opponent
right just a little change of decision
making and I feel like this is a bad
sign for Yan his position of course is
totally fine we're only six moves by
white into this game but the fact that
he keeps thinking he wants to take a
path and he wants to figure out what
direction this game goes in Knight C6 if
he were playing a bullet game he would
do this instantly without even thinking
but as we keep talking about he's
wondering if Bishop D3 that's a problem
for this light Square bishop and big
question actually is does Jan feel
comfortable in these types of structures
in where we have a car Carl's bot
structure we usually see a black having
the carlsbud structure and we get a
typical Pawn minority attack at some
point throwing the Pawns of the board to
challenge this extra Pawn on the queen
side but he's not really a caracon
player so maybe Jan just doesn't feel at
home in destruction and that's why ding
picked this opening
it's it's certainly possible and also I
like the general approach of keeping the
position closed as many pieces on the
board as possible pieces are not going
to be traded anytime soon you don't have
a release of tension you have the
tension remains in the position like in
that London game for a very long time so
basically
when you're under pressure and you
really want to draw the what you really
want just psychologically is a quick
um you know trade of pieces or
complications something that you can
calculate or even what we saw in the
last game we're doing had the white
pieces where we see a theoretical fight
uh Dion has to calculate some stuff goes
into an end game where he knows it's
kind of very much within the drawing
margin and
it's just kind of a smooth defense here
it's every move is a decision even if
it's a small decision every move is a
decision and I actually saw a fun line
in case of Bishop 5 which I was I wanted
to uh to mention after Bishop to F5 I'm
I'm thinking 95.
and how do you like how do you think you
would react to this move
I thought that was a rhetorical question
I was hoping it was but I guess let's
see what happens to you guys well here I
was wondering about Bishop to B5
as well it's it's definitely a question
because
if I play Bishop takes C6 you know I'm
spoiling your your Pawn structure
creating an outpost on the C5 script
potentially
I was kind of hoping you would play
Knight B to D7
instead of Knight C6
because I wanted to play F4
I know it looks a little bit uh you know
risky positionally risky but
I have some G4 ideas somewhere
not sure exactly where it might work out
but I don't see like a
why this is obviously bad you know you
can't exploit the E4 squares so easily
because White House has Bishop B5 ideas
so so there's definitely some Tactical
potential in the position
Bishop D7
wow that was not a move on our radar it
just feels a bit too passive one can
understand that it takes control of any
pins along this diagonal getting ready
for Knight C6 and wow I see uh Robert
that it's a bad move
into position yeah
I think we can understand why it doesn't
compete for the center in a meaningful
way it's uh developing it's at least off
its initial square but it doesn't
actually get onto a useful diagonal so I
believe that White's automatic move is
Knight to E5 here and this is honestly a
great outcome from the opening for
dingly Wren the position isn't that bad
for black we're not going to pretend
that it is but this was a mistake now I
think it's an objective mistake from the
sense of the evaluation clearly has
changed in White's favor uh but from a
as Bobby said pragmatic perspective
that's what John has been all match
that's how he chooses openings he's
saying the position will be Rock Solid
for black so let's say you want to go
and take this bishop then what there are
no real weaknesses in Black's Camp so I
I don't like the move I think it's very
passive it's not really in yon's style
quite honestly but I don't think it's
really that big of a deal it's not the
worst thing in the world we'll just see
how he plays the next few moves because
I would be Galloping my knight in the
center right now it might not be that
big of a deal but it's a little
something for ding to play with at this
very start of the open of the opening we
see a question mark being awarded to
this move Knight E5 jumping into the
center seems like a natural response and
once again it seems like Bishop D7
perhaps is a decision more based on the
result-oriented approach just trying not
to take too much risk being very solid
might not have been Yan's Choice had the
math situation been any different and
then continues with the development he
doesn't jump in with the Knight
immediately but first takes out the
bishop so no more black Bishop coming on
F5 the E5 square is always there white
simply wants to go shot Castle neck next
bring that Rook to E1 jump with that
Knight to E5 bring that other knight
from D2 to F3 really taking control of
the E5 Square Fabi what do you make of
this approach by Yan Bishop D7
slightly passive
yeah I I think I can only come up with
one explanation for this move which is
that he picked up the bishop and as he
was moving it suddenly he felt the urge
to sneeze and then before it could go to
F5 or G4 some like useful Square it just
his hand released it for a second on D7
where it does absolutely nothing and
um well maybe maybe it's super subtle
and I'm just not getting it but
like why couldn't you start with Knight
C6 and then if Bishop to E5 then you put
the bishop on D7
then the bishop serves a purpose there
and if Bishop D3 then you put the bishop
on G4 where it serves a purpose uh but
basically white should Castle here I
guess white can also play H3 to stop
Bishop G4 but okay let's say you castle
and then
if black plays E6 you kind of accept a
slightly worse position I think
white can play Rook to E1 for example
for uh and then let's say Bishop D6
white can even play Queen to E2 followed
by Knight to E5 out of standard stuff
you know Knight to E5 and Bishop on D7
is out of the game this is kind of
classical Carlsbad you know post up in
the center and I don't E5
um classic stuff how how you know you
might see in the good old days how
um people get outplayed in these types
of positions Knight F3 and so on and you
you start to attack on the king side and
he does indeed Castle ding his playing
quickly if you don't play E6 and you
play Bishop G4 you lost a Tempo so of
course you can and I actually think
maybe bishop G4 is the best move
but you just lost the tempo so I'm not
really
getting it and
and besides those moves I don't see any
like black obviously doesn't want a
castle Queen side because it's just
inviting a pawn storm you know
after Castle queenside okay maybe we can
stop
uh E5 Castle queenside is so risky that
it even like almost loses tonight to G5
which is kind of but there's Bishop to
E8 there but even without like winning
immediately white can simply play Rook
to E1 followed by A4 and uh and B4 and
so on you know standard uh Pawn storm on
the queen side
so does he want to play Bishop G4
maybe maybe it's the best approach but
didn't you just lose a tempo
like okay it could be super subtle it
could be that this is like the best
approach for black
but to my I it's kind of
strange
results is psychologically so difficult
to make the move the bishop G4 once
you've just played Bishop D7 one
development move and then to move the
bishop twice out of the opening even if
it is the best move in in the position
it's a hard one to me just to accept
that yes it was not the optimal decision
not the optimal choice for that Bishop
to move to that square and Fabi you said
a really insightful thing there that if
you're not sure in an opening where to
place a piece and you've got different
choices you can always start with
another move that you know you have to
make instead of moving picking up that
bishop and moving it to a square bring
out that knife the Knight has only one
good Square you want to place it on C6
and you can just keep the options open
keep it flexible and decide on the next
move where indeed you want to place the
bishop and as I speak in fact Yan does
go for a second move with the bishop and
he doesn't take much time for it he
plays Bishop G4 instantly is Yan still
familiar with this position or is this
some over-the-board inspiration what's
going on there Robert
I'm very surprised and I know that I was
saying Bishop D7 he's just trying to be
solid and you know it's not a good move
or it's not the opening theory that is
recommended to players but I do see that
even though he's losing a Tempo what do
you really get from that Tempo Black's
next moves will be E6 and the bishop is
outside the pawn chain there's
definitely a good thing for black E6
Bishop out to D6 castle at some point so
it's not like black is under immediate
threat which gives him this the time to
step on D7 just to go out to G4 it's
weird I don't know how this happened I
would never have predicted this in my
life that this bishop would make two
moves as early as move eight but E6 and
where is White going to strike the key
is covering this E5 Square rookie one
get this queen out of here play 95 at
some point that still is in the cards
but I just feel like black isn't risking
all that much just yet even though I am
very very shocked by the fact that he
played Bishop B7 and then Bishop G4
feels like he just gave Ding A tempo for
free
can we go back one move because
I'm thinking that of course this looks
strange but what if what if H3 here
I I think I mentioned this this was sort
of a possible option because I really
want to keep that Bishop bad on D7
and
and if E6 short Castle Bishop D6 rookie
one I did Black
what does black do exactly with this
Castle Queen E2
same plan uh I want to put the Knight on
E5
how does black make use of the fact that
we played H3 which is sort of a half uh
half tempo for black
like what's Black's plan here I don't
really see it
I think we're styling because we also
don't really see the exact plan is there
some kind of E5 available at some moment
that's really the big question because
if black can play E5 even though it gets
you an isolated D5 Pawn you get Space
breathing room for your pieces a rook on
E8 will be nice your Bishop 1 D7 will be
better but I don't think that E5 is
going to work out here I don't think
that you have time
and the reason why I say that is because
let's say after H3 that was probably the
only moment that I could see you playing
E5
and then I think D takes C5 Knight takes
E5 and queen to E2 is quite tragic for
black beans Bishop D6 we take an F4 also
take a knight of three but take an F4
okay good enough
and so E5 I don't see ever happening
because I always cover that move in time
and you don't even get the isolated Pawn
position which might also be better for
white
so
I understand why ding quickly castled
but maybe it was a moment for a bit of
subtlety and I really feel like Jan
makes something up in his prep like he's
going
maybe now he's again he's in something
familiar
but something was mixed up like
after the C3 it looks like he was a bit
surprised and that he quit he played
this bishop to D7
I don't feel like Bishop D7 was a good
move it also allowed Knight to E5 which
was super dangerous
uh or maybe not dangerous is maybe not
the right word but super interesting
uh if we go back to like Bishop d795
I really feel like that was an
interesting approach as well because
Knight C6 comes to mind but I don't want
to take on D7 I want to play F4 and I I
feel like this is a very very
interesting approach for white
um
you see I mean the engine is saying it's
kind of keeping it level the bar is
staying level but how are you
approaching this as well like if E6
Bishop D3 I think White's play is pretty
clear-cut Bishop D3 short castle and
this doesn't look very good
or at least very easy for black
so it's it's a genuine question maybe
black could play G6 instead of E6 and
tried to for the bishop on G7 and
efficient D3 maybe eventually Bishop to
F5 to trade the Bishops some kind of
these are sometimes ideas
right uh so
also it was a question
I can't imagine this was his prep Bishop
Queen C7 Bishop D7
Bobby the reason I'm laughing is because
after Knight E5 like in this variation
we're looking at here even if you don't
play F4 so we understand that F4
compromise some squares let's say you
just bring this Knight to F3 you're just
reinforcing your knight on the Square
this bishop is passive there was no
nothing gained for Black by putting the
bishop 1 D7 especially if E6 is the next
move you could have already had the dark
squared Bishop out instead of the light
Square Bishop which is not very active
so yeah it's very strange right we're
not going to deny it what Jan has done
thus far uh he just developed he could
have developed one more piece but
instead he put his Bishop on D7 only to
get to G4 I think we're going to be
racking our brains about this for a
while but maybe dingley Wren is already
regretting the fact that he didn't play
H3 maybe he thought you had to play
Bishop D7 there's no way he's going to
move that light score Bishop a second
time but he was maybe fooled a little
bit and if I'm ding I'm looking at Queen
A4 then I'm trying to get my knight to
E5 I feel like black still has some
things to work out here
well thank you natural moves after this
bishop D7 what surprises I think many of
us is just the speed
on came back to the board and made them
move Bishop G4 now they say don't move
the same piece twice in an opening and
Robert I just want to follow up on your
point to show what are the dangers that
actually exist in this position now ding
is of course contemplating a move like
H3 hitting the bishop but let's say he
goes with the idea of actually
sidestepping the pin so that he can
continue with the move Knight to E5 a
move like Queen C2 or queen A4 but even
I just wanna I just want to show a point
with Queen to C2 Queen A4 great move
they're pinning the Knight with a simple
developing move sidestepping with that
PIN if black continues with development
with a move like E6 you want to open up
that second Bishop in the position but
now you're one tempo to shot with your
king safety white can in fact jump with
the Knight all the way to E5 even though
the E5 square is defended by two pieces
in Black's camp but does black actually
have the option of picking up that pawn
Knight takes E5 you re recapture with
the pawn and if black gets greedy this
could be big trouble with a check coming
on B5 Bishop B5 check and suddenly
you're missing that one tempo which
you've just spent moving your own Bishop
twice these are the dangers that could
exist I see the eval bar still thinks
that black is doing fine but I would be
petrified here imagine a queen A4 or
Bishop B5 Knight D7 you recapture the
Knight give a check on A4 Robert instead
and then pick up the bishop there are
all these ideas that you need to watch
out for with the black pieces but for
now ding takes another approach he
decides not to step away with that Queen
these are the dangers in the position as
we're pointing at thing makes another
natural looking move not going for the
most direct line of trying to get that
Knight to E5 but brings The Rook to E1 a
move that at some point had to be played
yeah he's playing the moves that you
might kind of first come to mind right
so if you were playing uh quicker time
control game you might just quickly play
these moves like Bishop D3 Castle rookie
one
I'm not sure exactly what his plan is to
continue after E6
because white cannot post the Knight on
E5
and that's why you I think uh White
could definitely consider moving the
queen at some point to do so as you
mentioned
to play Queen C2 at someone but black is
in time now to prevent that Knight E5
for for sure because E6
followed by Bishop D6 you'll no longer
have any 95 ideas
so the question is do you want to play
E6 Knight F1 Bishop D6 Knight G3 I
really don't like the Knight on G3 so I
don't think that that should be your
approach
um even if you gain the bishop pair of
Bishop takes F3 I'm not sure the Knight
on G3 is really well placed and even
Castle here
I think you can play H3 Bishop F3 Queen
F3
is this actually getting nicer white I
mean yes I would think
I would still think that black is doing
okay here because it's it's so solid and
all the pieces are well placed but maybe
the bishop pair really does count for
quite a lot and and we might easily see
the move Knight to F1 now
but these guys are playing so fast so my
thought was
that maybe we transposed to something
that Jan knows
and so he mixed it up in terms of it
wasn't after C3
maybe it was after Bishop to D3 instead
of C3
and maybe we transposed to his prep
but C3 was was a different story
entirely and that's why Bishop D7 was a
mistake there
right but we if we did transpose to his
prep it cost him a Tempo because there's
no prep where he played Bishop D7 and
then Bishop G4 so that's what I'm saying
maybe bishop D3 Bishop D7 is the idea
if we go back I don't know if we want to
go back when they're blitzing out the
moves so quickly but
uh okay we're gonna probably see Knight
to G3 now
Knight to G3 because
obviously white wants to get that Bishop
but H3 would allow Bishop H5 followed by
Bishop G6 and the trade of light Square
Bishops and uh and we can definitely
talk about trader Bishops as good or bad
in this position I think the trade of
light Square Bishops is good for black
because
imagine that Bishop wants C8 completely
passive versus the bishop 1 D3 and
attacking peace aiming at the king side
black is almost always happy to trade
those Bishops off so H3 only facilitates
Plex
positional goal besides the fact that
after H3 Bishop page five I can't even
get the bishop kicked away from H5 so
you can't break the pin because now
Knight G3 allows Bishop takes G3
so 923 here uh I think having said a at
this point ding must say B he must go
Knight G3 otherwise there was no point
to his previous play
so Knight G3 I think will be seen
and okay there's this like funny H5 I
don't know
if it's it's probably what it should be
G5
the players just keep surprising us with
the bishop moves what on Earth is going
on here Knight G3 but ding going for
Bishop G5 I don't believe he's actually
threatening to take on F6 with white
having castled on the king side do you
really want to take chances opening up
the G file yeah and hasn't committed
with his own King position he very well
at some point could actually decide to
go long castle and build his own chances
and Bobby you were very surprised with
the move Bishop G5 but the more you look
at it well it feels like
another natural move in the position it
is a developing move what caused that
little surprise by you there
no it's it's sensible when I think about
it but I think the reason why I was
surprised is because
I didn't really see the idea now I see
that white does have 93 ideas
exploiting that potential you know
Knight takes D5 for example Knight to D7
here comes to mind but then maybe Knight
to E3
is quite interesting
is Bishop takes up three Queen takes F3
why does not at all worried about the H2
pod being hanging because uh this would
probably be very very bad King H1 Bishop
should drop back otherwise it gets
trapped and then Knight takes D5 and
obviously things have started to go
quite wrong in touch position
uh we're already thinking about you know
some potential sacrifices on E6 and some
potential mates but white doesn't even
have to sacrifice material right and
it's just positionally black is in so
much trouble
so Bishop G5 has those ideas
it just it's it's not something you
usually see I think Bishop G5 and
Carlsbad structures right not super
often
no you but Fabi I think this what ding
is doing is he's discouraging Jan from
castling kingside and it is true that
black can Castle Queen side but this is
what we've been talking about from the
start ding wants a position where kings
are on opposite side of the board he
wants to be able to attack yawn and so
even though this opening has been very
strange would we'd have to really dive
into the nuances to better understand it
and I think the players maybe aren't
fully aware of how each move has changed
the position but I like what he's doing
because if you Castle kingside are you
really prepared for Bishop takes F6 Pawn
F6 and your king feels a little bit open
over there I actually do think that Ding
is playing this quite interestingly and
this enterprising style is what he needs
to score a point and he is putting Jan
into the think tank he's ahead on the
clock and that's not something we can
say that often in this match
I love it I love what you're saying that
a potential opening outcome where we've
got opposite side castling we know that
would mean an exciting middle game of
course now if Black Goes shot Castle
here you will pick up that F6 Knight
without thinking but the question is
Robert if black was to play 8-6 instead
I hit that Bishop is doing anyway
planning to pick up that Knight on F6
allowing these positions with the long
Castle Bishop takes F6 G takes F6 at
some point my idea is clear with black I
want to go long Castle put my Rook on G8
and start asking questions on the G line
Fabi who do you think is kind of a trade
and this imbalance in the position would
favor
I think the question here is simply is
Knight to E3 strong
it kind of forces I think Bishop takes
up three most likely Bishop three Queen
F3 and long
castle and okay the question is first
from a positional point of view is this
good for black because uh you are
inviting some potential Pawn storms uh
also you are inviting the trade of F6
for the H2 bonds but maybe that's a good
trade because Queen F6 Bishop H2 King
goes somewhere Bishop to F4
and uh white king is someone weakened so
I guess black is not too worried about
this one and then I guess most likely
white will play G3
instead of Queen takes of six but okay
you can defend this Pawn
with G3 or H3 it's it's a bit of a
question
and then probably F5
and then this is like you know standard
race uh
B4 you know E4 uh H5 B5 this is sort of
Pawn storm
did castle kingside by the way so he is
unafraid he does not think Bishop takes
F6 would be a problem yet this opposite
size castling would have given us quite
an adventure uh but maybe Jan saying
Bishop F6 doesn't threaten anything and
to answer your earlier question ton of
H6 at some point white can do what we
were saying black might think about
bringing the bishop around just to get
control of his E5 Square so maybe ding
is playing this positionally rather than
going for any sort of tactics but of
course you must calculate Bishop takes
F6 gf6 and what happens in the resulting
position to the black king
board you you know that your opponent
can destroy the pawn shield in front of
your own King and you yet bravely just
take a decision like that to go short
Castle inviting Bishop F6 inviting this
uh these Pawns in front of Black's King
to be actually destroyed for the rest of
the game a double Pawn on the F line and
Fabi I want to understand this I mean is
this uh what is what is blacks what does
black get in return for something like
this which feels like a big compromise
on the king side to me
yeah black gets the bishop pair and
black also gets uh some other ideas so
let's say you take on F6
take and you play some waiting move just
to illustrate like lets you play A3
and I would like to play Bishop H5 here
with black
uh there's also E5 ideas so maybe
there's even some tactics there but
Bishop H5 followed by Bishop G6 and
followed by at some point preparing the
move E5
and the doubled F pawns are usually not
a big concern with the bishop G6 because
that that Bishop almost acts as a pawn
it acts as a Defender
there's like even some lines from the
caracon where uh you know you have have
this sort of thing where you allow
doubling of your Pawns in that case it's
where like sometimes in the caracon the
advanced variation black plays Knight to
H6
and uh White father with Bishop takes H6
and likely G takes H6 and you'd think
how could you do this to your Pawn
structure but then the bishop which is
on F5 and the heracon drops back to G6
and it turns out that the bishop is a is
a wonderful Defender and the more uh
Salient Factory is the bishop hair the
bishop on D6 in this case is a very
strong uh piece it controls the dark
squares in a way that whites pieces
cannot do in the same way right it
allows things like here Queen to D2
there's Bishop F4 these sorts of ideas
right
so let's go back because I I see
concrete lines first thing I think of
after Castle uh it's Bishop takes F6 G
takes F6 followed by Knight to G3 with
with the very
standards uh or very clear idea of
preventing Bishop H5 and preparing H3
and here I'm wondering how how black
would react to this it's kind of like I
think you probably will give the bishop
uh you could play F5 Maybe
H3
and I guess Bishop takes F3
Queen takes F3 and you might consider I
don't know immediately or or maybe King
h8 but you might consider Bishop takes
G3 as well but I would think King h8 all
by root to G8 and
I could put a knight on H5 but I could
put a rook on GN it's just a very
complex position
but it's not clear how white is
attacking here so
given that it might be completely fine
for black you have some kind of G4 it's
I mean you definitely have your ideas
here
G4 uh followed by King K1 obviously you
can't take on G4 because it's simply
Checkmate after Queen F6
so
yeah this this is disaster so after G4 I
don't know exactly what black does you
can play Maybe
Queen to d8
and a discouraging any sort of King H1
and preparing fg4 but it's it's a tough
fight this this could go on and on and
who knows who's better either side could
be better
I love these lines that you're showing
Fabi because in all of them one things
for sure that it's going to be a very
complex and a dynamic middle game
position despite having a slow opening
start but it looks like ding has managed
to create something and we might be
seeing that Forest of complications
after the trade on F6 while ding is in a
think right now trying to navigate his
advantages the pros and cons of this
trade we will go into a shot break and
be back with ding's decision fire on
board is coming up
foreign
[Music]
hi everybody International Master Danny
wrench here chess.com's Chief chess
officer we are here and excited to be
collaborating and partnering with World
Quant as an official partner of the
champions tour in the year 2023 I'm now
speaking with Chief strategy officer for
World Quant natish mining the people
have met us and now time for the big
questions jumping right into the basics
tell everybody a little more about world
quad and what exactly is it that world
quad does thank you for having me Danny
and you already introduced me I'm the
chief strategy officer at World Quant
World Quant is a global asset management
organization it was founded by Igor
tulchinski in 2007. World Quan today has
over 850 employees who are working
towards designing investment strategies
in multiple asset class across Global
markets World Quant believes in
empowering the ideas of the talent
across the globe and we have 23 offices
in 13 countries today amazing amazing
stuff so tell us now a little bit more
about this project called World Quant
brain so worldcoin is built on the
belief that Talent is global but
opportunity is not and we strive to take
this opportunity to everyone around the
globe world Quant brain has been
designed as a tool which empowers us to
take that opportunity to anyone that's
fantastic seriously that's amazing I I
had no idea about that learning about
this along with our viewers and
obviously as a as a website in a company
with a mission to also connect Global
communities and increase the opportunity
for chess that makes it even more of a
natural partnership tell me a little bit
more from World quads perspective why
you guys run the iqc so World Quant has
this mission of democratizing
quantitative finance and international
Quant Championship is one of the tools
we have to spread the message about this
operator opportunity which World point
is offering to everyone to be a Quant in
the world of in the quantitative space
and international Quant Championship
empowers the individuals to utilize
their ideas and show that they can do it
and gives us an opportunity to take this
message to them wherever they are that's
great now you said the finals will be in
person was I write that it'll be in the
Bahamas that sounds like a pretty great
location can I come yeah absolutely
absolutely and I can okay so I don't
know that I'm qualified to be in the iqc
but uh tell everybody a little more so
the finals are going to be in the
Bahamas what will that be like for those
who make it yes so the finals as you
said is planned to be in Bahamas for the
iqc so worldcoin celebrated its 15th
anniversary last year in 2022 to
celebrate that occasion we are getting
the whole world Quant organization
together in Bahamas this year and we
decided that we will organize the finals
of iqc at that event so this will give
an opportunity to our finalists to meet
the world Quant team in person it will
give them an opportunity to watch the
culture and rigor of the organization
and we are very excited that everybody
will be able to get together at that
event in Bahamas well this has been
awesome nitish thank you so much this is
where I remind everybody it's their
chance to get involved in the iqc the
international quad Championship you can
use the command iqc you can visit the
world Quant brain website we encourage
you to do so ASAP registration is open
until May so it's time to jump in and
maybe you'll get to meet the CSO and
others in the Bahamas maybe I'll be
there I don't if I'm lucky I don't know
but it sounds like a great time either
way and the Tish uh the Chess World and
the Champions chess tour thanks World
Quant for their partnership and we're
looking forward to the rest of the year
together thank you Denny and good luck
to the community for participating in
iqc
thank you
[Music]
foreign
World Quant is an official partner of
the chesscom broadcast of the fideo
World Championship they are a global
firm that builds complex mathematical
models to identify market inefficiencies
now World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quan
championship and the chess Community to
hunt down the next generation of Quant
Finance Specialists because nobody knows
how to analyze a position better than a
chess player right if you think you have
what it takes register for the
international one Championship head to
go.chess.com iqc or use command iqc in
chat and more details and we are back
with a game 12. Tingler and has been in
the thing for about 11 minutes in this
position surprised by Yan speed and
decision to actually go for short Castle
he still hasn't taken the decision to
trade on F6 the positional imbalances
that we were talking about but given the
math situation Robert is that the best
decision for ding does he need to grab
an F6 regardless of how it is
objectively
well I guess part of the answer to the
question is what is Black's next move
and we handed Yan a free turn what would
he do I don't necessarily think there's
a great place to move the Knight he can
hop back to D7 for sure uh but I'm not
sure ding is afraid of that and so uh
Bishop takes F6 G takes F6 that will
change the complexion of the game it'll
become into more tactical Waters and the
big question is is the bishop on D6 is
that better than the Knight that white
will have remaining on the board so
these are very difficult questions to
answer which is why ding has been
thinking for now over 11 minutes uh he's
spending a lot of time here because it
is a critical decision it changes the
nature of the game entirely
yeah this is a really big moment because
Bishop takes F6 it could be good
it could turn out well or it could
actually turn out very well for black
and you're taking some risk with white
once you do that I am looking at a move
I think Robert that you didn't mention
this idea I don't know if it was in this
position or a similar one but it's an
appealing idea and it's to play Bishop
to H4 here
which is mimicking Black's idea of
Bishop H5 G6
uh the bishop on D6 is an excellent
piece so why he's just trying to trade
it off and it would crucially uh kind of
slightly weaken that E5 square right so
at some point in the future
yeah there there might be a night coming
to E5 probably Knight takes G3
but maybe black would also just at some
point capture on F3 maybe like Rook fd8
here
and then try to like H3 Bishop three
Queen F3 and E5 would be
one of those standard
ideas for black and
D takes E5 Knight takes E5 maybe White's
a bit better after Queen to F4 but
uh I don't know it might also be very
very close to equal because
I think it would be completely equal if
black could get like Queen D6 G6 here
but if you if they're not F5 is kind of
coming into the game at some moment then
it could be a little bit unpleasant for
black as well so
for example
can I play Rook to E7
ideas Knight of Five Night takes D3 no
five oh you trickster I was gonna say
that was that was my idea I uh I I did I
did come with a plan but it's some sort
of mess because you can take on E7 twice
and then Knight takes a four Rook takes
B7
and it's one of those difficult end
games to evaluate because it's the Rook
Rooks against the knights
with some past pawns as well
you're a Madman Bobby you really are you
come up with these crazy lines and the
evaluation bars it's ever so slightly
better for black but it's a type of I'm
gonna put advantage in air quotes
because if you make one mistake you
might just be lost at some point because
White's pawns do push up the board quite
quickly and that could be dangerous and
I just wanted to stop uh take a moment
at this position here and say that there
are very few people who actually enjoy
playing with the isolated Pawn at the
highest level you get activity around
the pawn because when you have an
isolated Pawn inherent to that is you
have opened files on the adjacent lines
but you have this long-term issue that
you have to keep defended and you can't
defend it with a pawn as the C3 Pawn is
defended by a pawn that's good it means
you can use your piece elsewhere you
often need to have a piece tied down to
this Pawn on D5 so I think Bobby made
some great points there showing that
there are some concrete variations that
allow black to make moves like rookie
seven even though it would seem risky
with a knight going F5 but I think if
white has a few turns just consolidate I
think this could be a long-term issue
for black in a position like this
I think it's it's a possibly it's not
really a relevant variation because you
made this half move A6 kind of to
illustrate White's idea which most
likely would never be played by Eon he
would probably choose a more
um a move which meets the demands of his
position more so but still Bishop stage
four does come to mind as a very
relevant idea
and also white could first kick the
bishop like let's say you played A6
again I could consider kicking the
bishop back with H3 first and then after
Bishop to H5 then maybe bishop to G3
and maybe I'll gain like the H3 Tempo
here
possibly it's it's not a hundred percent
certain that this move matters at all
but
uh also I I just want to point out that
Bishop to H4
it does kind of
um stop this 97 that you were you were
mentioning
because Knight D7 would just lose a pawn
due to the tactic Bishop takes H7 King
takes H7 Knight to G5
followed by Queen takes G4 and white has
one material and
obviously this this is not something
that Yan would fall for but
but just to point out why the bishop 184
might be a bit better than on G5
wow there are definitely some tactics
that Yan needs to watch out for he needs
to keep that bishop and G4 Defender and
you guys are looking at these lines
Robert with the retreat of the bishop I
just really feel that if you are in a
situation in a world championship match
where you need to score that point where
you need to find your chances and you
don't see anything immediately wrong
with the move like Bishop F6 it uh it's
it doesn't lose on the spot for white in
fact it keeps a balance in the position
but in a dynamic way and maybe that is
the option that you need to go for
instead of something where you can just
have this slight pull for a long game
Yan might be able to keep that under
control Bishop F6 G takes F6 and I want
to take a look at some of those lines as
well but before we do that Robert I want
to ask you those kind of positions and
those kind of dynamic imbalances is that
also something that stylistically Yan
would be happy to get into he'd be
thrilled and I think we say this
regularly when there's a choice let's
say in a rook end game where you can
defend passively with even material or
defend actively down upon most players
choose the activity that's how much they
want options for their pieces we love
optionality we love flexibility as chess
players we want to have choice so in a
position like Bishop takes Knight Pawn
takes when this King steps aside Rook G
we see all sorts of plans for black that
are of your own making whereas if you
see a position with Bishop H4 Bishop G3
you're kind of like uh what am I really
doing over here because let's just make
a move like Bishop H5 and get to a
position that I think is interesting is
that white still feels like the side for
choice because you get to hop into the
center first and you're just a little
bit more active now this line is even
black Is Not In Harm's Way but I'm just
trying to make the point that oftentimes
we would prefer chaos and activity over
uh little solid position where our
opponent is playing for two results I
just think that Jan he would like to
enjoy his position a little more where
he has chances of his own even though
he's not playing for a win necessarily I
think that will help him in his path in
his quest to trying to just hold on to
this game and have two games remaining
where it keeps that one point lead
let's move 12 for Ding and he's almost
in a 20 minute think about this very
critical decision which will pretty much
set the tone for the rest of the game
does he go for a more positional
approach with Bishop H4 or grab that
Knight and go for these imbalanced
middle games that we have been looking
at where either of the players can go
wrong and once again ding has to take
calculated risk in this game he can't go
all out he can't get super rushed
because if it backfires that would be
match over now with this 20 minute think
Robert that Ding is in it's only move
12.
kind of reaching that point where ding
needs to make that decision fast now is
still a bunch of moves to be made and I
know he's got time on the clock with
bigger decisions lie ahead of him how
much more time candy afford to take for
this one well just like I did pre-game
when you asked her with the opening I'm
gonna do the same thing okay so Fabiano
uh you played in a world championship
you play against these two all the time
so how much more time can ding spend on
this move and do you think he will and
should play Bishop takes up six here
I think it's a it's a moment where you
should be spending time but also I think
that he could have saved himself
spending time here by taking a bit of
time earlier when he was rushing through
some decisions that as we saw were not
so straightforward
um at Bishop D3 Knight E5 was an option
I think especially castled and if he had
made that H3 move I think it would have
been really unpleasant for yon to have
come up with like a very obvious
continuation and he would have secured a
slight advantage while here it looks
like Jan's moves have kind of seems to
know what to do in the position he's
playing quite well quite quickly but if
if thing had played H3 I don't think it
would have been so simple for black
and I actually saw a tweet by Anish
where he was looking for where Bishop to
D7 is the engine's recommendation
in which position does the engine
actually say you should play Bishop V7
here and he found a position
where the engine likes it
and it was if Jan had played Knight to
C6 instead of Bishop to D7
Queen C2 and here Anish says Bishop D7
is the computer's first choice and I
assume he's talking about a very strong
computer because
I I don't think this is a weaker engine
would understand why you play Bishop D7
even here
but and I I don't understand it either
but I guess it's because Bishop G4 is
met by Bishop to B5
so
you you play Bishop D7 first and then
you wait for something
and I still don't really understand it
but
okay let's trust Anish and his
and his engine structure is very
powerful
but
no longer relevant to the game position
just just kind of funny to think about
like why Jan played Bishop D7 where it
was in his preparation
where he came up with this idea which is
so
unusual
yeah definitely very unusual especially
how quickly he moved that Bishop on the
next move to G4 so it's something that
he's seen in a similar position so very
insightful there as you mentioned that
perhaps just mixing it up a little bit
uh with this queen C2 and feeling that
there is a transposition and it looks
like Jan's the one who's feeling the
comfort in this position thing head and
hands there is that a sign that he's not
feeling as confident if you have to take
that decision of grabbing that Knight
you probably would have done that a
couple of minutes ago now Crossing that
20 minute Mark I'm getting the feeling
that Ding is feeling shaky right now not
as confident is that the feeling right
now Robert
yeah I mean the more he thinks the more
I'm a bit concerned for him but perhaps
the more likely it is that he takes on
F6 I mean sometimes you can convince
yourself to do something because you're
like I burned so much clock I'm trying
to analyze this position and it does
change the entire nature of the game and
maybe even the match because the last
few games have been very solid there
have not been chances for dingly rent to
play for a win he desperately needs a
win so I could see him making the choice
but yeah he's spending a lot of time
it's been over 22 minutes at this point
and
taking on F6 allowing the pawn to
capture back that opens up the G file
that gives yarn some necessary play in
this position I think a ding from the
start of this game he just wanted to
have a slow build up he wanted to have a
small plus and try to work it like he
did in the London system game so he just
has to move honestly it's hard for me to
say that or I should say it's easy for
me to say that because I'm sitting here
just talking about the chess while he's
playing it has to deal with every single
repercussion but I feel like being down
on the clock has not helpeding at all
throughout this match
so I was thinking of some funny lines
and I think I I see a very weird draw
with the move nobody would ever Bobby
don't say the d word we talked about
this
I'll try not to try not to say the d
word
but in this case
uh there's Queen to D2 which is also a d
word I guess
going to D2
and at first you think like oh Bishop
takes F3 you're ruining your password
but this bishop takes up six
and the draw I saw was G takes up six
maybe this bishop F4 as well Queen to H6
Bishop to E4
Rook takes C4 D takes E4 Bishop takes E4
F5 defending Checkmate Queen G5
and and there that's your d word Robert
the only Diva that Ding is thinking
about is getting that dub in some
somehow in this position but he needs to
make a decision fast the line that
you're saying probably not gonna happen
in a million years right now uh it is
impossible to imagine being walking into
something like this and currently still
in that Think Tank I'm I'm getting
worried for ding here guys I'm I'm
actually thinking like one he needs to
make a move and second he needs to show
more confidence in this position and in
his body language I know body language
is a controversial topic but just
looking at ding right now I have to ask
you Fabi do you feel that it is an
aspect that has been missing from doing
in this world championship match so far
where one has just been able to say that
well ding it looks good he's kept things
under control nerves under control does
it look to you that in fact ding has
been shaky
well I think it's just this is why I try
not to read too much into body language
because if you look at ding during
pretty much any game he he rarely looks
uh you know super confident or pumped up
I think that's just his demeanor and
that doesn't mean that he's not
confident it's just how how he expresses
himself is
um you know we can think about like the
the super expressive guys like Hikaru
Anish uh Yan these guys who wear their
emotions on their sleeve I don't think
ding is one of those guys so uh even if
he's like completely winning he rarely
shows
extreme excitement you can kind of see
you can see if you if you know him well
when he's
um when he's starting to really like his
position but
I've seen him in good positions looking
worried it could just be that he's
concentrated in calculating it's not
something I would read too much into I
think I say that a lot yeah body
language not not easy to read into
everyone has uh has a different way of
expressing himself especially at a
chessboard when there's so much going
through your mind and
um even sometimes the players have no
idea what they're thinking right they're
they're like going through a million
moves a minute and uh
it's not like
even they always know that the
evaluation is this right we're seeing
the bar they have no idea what the
evaluation is they might think more or
less it's equal or slightly better for
white but the truth of the position
they're trying to figure out in real
time
I I want to suggest another
weird move this one doesn't lead to a
draw so you can you can thank me for
that it probably leads to a bad position
for white but I'll still suggest it
move Rook to E3
I know it's ugly
um
wait it's not that bad
not that bad oh wow so my idea was just
to free the queen to play Queen C2
and I was thinking of Bishop to H5 then
now Knight to G3 and I've attacked that
Bishop you know uh so it justifies
provoking the bishop back if Bishop G6
now maybe we could take one of six under
very good circumstances or we could take
on G6 and maybe even play that
um
take on G6 and
some move here I'm not sure exactly what
but
Queen to D3 is well I guess
it's not obvious why why would go for
this but okay it's some sort of
Direction
so
maybe it's also stupid
yeah
one idea Rook E3 that didn't come to my
mind I mean I was trying to make bishop
takes F6 work I was thinking about
Knight G3 just trying to go after this
bishop but this was bothering me after
Knight G3 I was wondering if the Knight
could move and hop over to H5 just
offering a trade of knights and it
seemed to solve many of Black's problems
here if you can get these Knights off
the board because Bishop takes F6 was
the one kind of threat in the position
and we don't mind taking on H5 with our
Bishop to get back to G6
yeah I think it's it's probably a very
good idea
because you um if you allow Knight takes
G3 and play H takes D3 then it's very
difficult
to remove that Bishop from G4
uh but also it's not clear exactly how
white would respond without my text H5
because Queen C2 would allow Bishop
does a lot Bishop of three
because three Bishop H7 oh he took an F6
though
I'm relieved to see that that decision
by doing the more lines that we were
looking into it just feels like this is
where the chances can be and well
finally after a long thing uh ding does
decide to go for the approach that
guarantees the most fun in the middle
game for all of us Bishop F6 Yan will
undoubtedly come back and recapture in
seconds and now ding has to think about
what really the follow-up is the second
world champion Emmanuel said if you see
a good move
find a better one now in classical chess
the thought that has been echoed by top
players often is that if you're going to
a think tank that's more than 15 minutes
you're not actually finding anything new
in the position but in fact you're just
double checking and sometimes doubting
your own decisions thing has to make
sure that's not the case for him Yan
recaptures and ding plays the move
immediately so this is what he was
thinking about the follow-up the Knight
comes to G3 threats are pushing that
pawn H3 forcing black to take a decision
with the bishop on G4 uh in the air
Bobby happy with this decision finally
made by ding we capture on F6 fun metal
game for all of us
it's definitely fun and it was what we
were analyzing a little bit right we
said the move F5 here H3 taking off
through Queen F3 and some sort of very
complex flight on the king side the
queen side action is uh is paused all
right we're not going to see anything
happen there there's no point for either
side to do anything on the queen side
you know no standard B5 B4 ideas all the
action is direct to the king side I'm
wondering about the move King to h8 as
well
very natural it might even be the first
move which comes to mind
White's only idea with this is to play
H3
otherwise I don't see a point
and
I'm kind of wondering
um
it was Bishop takes a three forced or
because black can take and play play F5
here
's Bishop takes G3
but there's also Bishop takes H3 I mean
it's it's actually an option because
here here's this
because GH3 now we can take on G3 what
is this take take and King to H1
this works out for one right
yeah because you have Knight H2 to block
a check I think fabies think if black
can take on H3 and open this King but
when this Knight comes back to H2 what's
the material count is it three pawns for
this Knight
three pawns but the piece is more
valuable because the pawns are not
passed they're not well I guess F pawns
and H pawns are passed but they're not
really dangerous for the moment yeah so
but wait what about
um
yes Bobby because I think this could be
really dangerous and maybe to think
about whether to play Rook G8 before
giving a check on H3 or even with the
queen on G3 because you're threatening a
mate in one on G2 and Robert if you just
back up rook G8 in this position this
bishop H3 sacrifice because the eval bar
approves it looks like something that
could be a point of worry for White
Queen E2 is the move that comes to mind
is there another defense and then you
pick up the H3 Pawn with a check was the
idea I wanted to check with you Knight
H2 bring up that Rook into the attack
Robert I'm hoping you'll help me with
the square maybe to G3 with the tempo
hit that Bishop get that other Rook on
to G8 this looks like dangerous
territory for white
I don't like it I think I don't like it
for black I should say because I feel
like you're not gonna Checkmate the
white king and once pieces get traded
only black has the opportunity to lose
this game because the material imbalance
is such that white has a bishop for
three pawns but as Fabi was saying with
the double Pawn that's not as easy to
get them rolling I think this would be
taking way too much risk for Yonder palm
tree and there's another variation I
want to go down which actually has the
same material imbalance but colors
reverse so if we go back after Knight G3
sorry what's up Robert yeah I just like
I I really think that it could be a very
important line but not specifically this
one I was thinking like you don't have
to take on G3 immediately
you can play Rook to G8 and it
I was just like wondering about this one
here uh instead of taking on G3 like
with the instead of taking with the
bishop on G3
because you kind of I think are
like King H1 makes sense right and
so if take on G3 take now I take with
the Rook
and it's kind of a different story
because there will be like Rook G8
followed by Rook G2 ideas and it looks
like the Queen's more active on G3 but
I feel like this is really dangerous
like Knight H2 Rook to G8
yeah okay so you defend
you defend against it
I mean even Rook G2 is a big question
because the queen in an open position
uh could cause somehow apparently not
you know apparently not Rook G2 but but
I I think I could sense it Fabi I know
you well enough you're coming to be like
oh I if I don't see anything concrete
here then white should have the
long-term Advantage practically speaking
even if the eval Bar says zeros
yeah I definitely agree I I was just I I
have this feeling that there's something
concrete here like maybe E5 or something
but I don't 100 see it
I I just I'm getting
the Spidey senses is tingling
that being said yeah if you don't see it
then you probably don't go for this with
black no it's absolutely correct it's
such a deep line and actually what I was
gonna show was let's say you do play
King to h8 and we get this normal
variation where this Pawn of six is
under attack Queen H5 is a threat you
play F5 I was wondering can ding take on
F5 this is It's the colors reversed of
three pawns for a piece but in a
situation like this I'm threatening
Checkmate you play F6 and can I just
take a third pawn and say all right
let's see how this game goes
I like it yeah three pawns and The
obscillary Bishop's AIDS in and the
attack the bishop on D3 is
it's a better piece than the bishop on
D6 because black has less pawns to
potentially blunt it
so I don't know I I intuitively looks
very nice for white I see the velbar is
not super excited but in a practical
game I would if given a choice I would
probably pick the white pieces because
let's say Rook d8 Queen
either to H5 or to F3 it's hard maybe F3
right
because you Queen H5 queen of seven
maybe you don't want to trade Queens
Queen F3 followed by Rook to E6 Rook to
E1
I'm having more fun with white than with
black in this position
for sure no I mean this entire position
looks scarier for the black king the
Knight isn't really playing it's not
influencing the position very much so I
feel like is this what ding is going for
because I was trying to work out where
he could possibly play for an edge and
this at least creates an imbalance and
one that seems at least easier to play
for white
that would be a big decision by then to
go for these complications sacrificing a
piece a very committal one because now
you kind of just have to start thinking
about building an attack and games would
probably be very difficult for white in
this so if you take this committal
decision you really have to be sure
about your chances and given the math
situation it would be a big decision by
doing but that's what he has to do he
has to find those moments those
complications where he does give Jan the
opportunity to go wrong as well and as
chart is pointing out that Ian is now
the one who's going into a thing and
we're getting some fun facts and stats
from our team that that 20 over 25
minute think that thing just went into
on the previous move uh before deciding
to take on F6 with this big decision it
was his third longest think for one move
in this world championship match he had
a longer think in game two and in in
game four as well but he's along with
the white pieces and game two was the
one that Yan won with black so again
just repeating this that Ding needs to
be careful with his clock management he
has to be judicious about his time
management yes that was a big decision
he took his time for it but I'm
expecting ding now to play a little
faster to pick up the momentum will he
take these decisions of these sacrifices
that you're pointing out on Knight G3 is
on the board and Jan's the one who's
thinking whether to trade the bishop for
the Knight what are the other
Alternatives that Yan can perhaps be
looking at in this position to keep
things and material more balanced here
I think F5 is a very natural move
and
it's a bit less exciting
unfortunately but like F5 H3 take take
and besides allowing the sacrifice that
Robert mentioned I'm not sure I like
Bishop takes u3 I think probably
probably white is better there because
you can play G4 I can get you a G4 it's
starting to get very dangerous for the
black king
because you have that extra G Pawn as
like a battering ram
but maybe Knight to E7 is a sensible
option
on the other hand I don't like spending
time on the movement Knight to E7 here
because Knight to H5 followed by G4
King dhh G4 what is this position it's
it's a very
unclear one
but it's very dangerous very dangerous
for black as well
yeah I was about to agree with you and I
was thinking you know we looked at
Knight takes F5 but even these Knight H5
variations they look worrisome for black
because there's this tension on F5 this
Kink can step out the way of the G file
and you really are never taking on G4 uh
there's Queen F6 Checkmate immediately
but even if I didn't Checkmate you let's
say I just took back with the pawn right
Let's ignore the Checkmate for the
moment you see white cell is a huge
Advantage because Checkmate will be on
tap H7 is threatened my queen stares
down to F7 as well this does not seem
like a position you want from Black's
perspective so I really like your knight
H5 idea from earlier and in this
position as well so maybe ding does have
options here and that's what Yan is a
little bit worried about he just sees
that his choices he has a few of them
he's going to have to play F5 but this
Knight very well may land on that H5
square or sacrifice on F5 I kind of like
Knight H5 it is more after we just look
through that line yeah it's a big choice
for y'all now because he can sack a
piece or he can allow those and let's
let's go down that line a little bit
more because
I feel like there was a very interesting
option for black at the end of it there
after G4 I just noticed this uh Dynamic
option
and it's a line which could easily
happen so like all these lines are are
definitely irrelevant so F5 H3
take take Knight D7 in case he's worried
about Knight takes if I'm not sure he
would be Knight to H5 Castle G4
sorry that is G4 and Knight to G6 is
super tempting G takes a five
I think y should go for it Knight to H4
so queen queen to G4 loses a queen so
Queen to E3 I was thinking
yeah this is this is dead in the water
and okay white has enormous direct Queen
to H6 followed by Queen G7 queen of six
Etc but Rook G8 how does this continue
because it's very concrete King
can go to either Square I think uh and
it's hard to say which one king H1
there's Rook to G2
uh
what's going on Queen H6
Rook H2 King G1
and Rook probably just uh
loses but
oh is there wait what is it what is the
refutation here is it like some kind of
queen E7 simple move or something or
that looks scary because F6 yeah it's
not obvious white has it a lot of
threats so
we can we can figure this out
wait Rook to G2 uh Queen F6 King G8 so
Rook 8 to G2
yeah
oh oh or not because Queen takes H4 oh
there's Queen F6 Queen H4
that is sickening the queen actually
goes back to steal the Knight and that
would be in fact winning for white these
lines are crazy why is why is chess so
difficult
where's the win it's it's so not obvious
here like it's it's really um
really looks like you might just get
mated with black in this position is it
this move don't tell me it's this move
Rook F2 oh Queen H2 now yeah it's
gorgeous
that's a nice move
oh nope it's not that either what
Rook how do we
takes up two is not the move
uh
is it uh
how do we find this
I'm so confused
because Queen H7 is Checkmate I'm really
searching hard in this position
that's lacking here
this is what happens right people think
oh but chess is so easy it's completely
winning what's wrong with you what's
wrong with them but where's the win here
because this King can always slink out
to E2
because Rook G1 King G1 doesn't seem to
change anything
yeah so yeah just right yeah it just
gives a rook
so like the Tactical options are what
are your Tactical options I mean you can
block the made on H7 but
what does that like achieve like night
of five Bishop takes a five E takes a
five
easy
this is it really this is winning oh oh
whoa it wasn't now you take on F2 now
you take on it now it's Rook F2 King F2
Queen H2
no
oh Queen so easy Force Checkmate oh okay
oh my goodness this is like a stuff out
of the puzzle books that's actually sick
you distract the Bishop from the
diagonal you can't move his King on the
G file thank you Fabi this was really
bothering me and rookie 2 takes away the
king's Escape square and Rook hitch one
that is
okay this is difficult I think this
queen C4 wasn't too difficult it was
just some blindness
uh yeah because we're looking in this
direction yeah we were looking with the
queen coming to H2 and it was an
unexpected uh direction for the queen
but yeah these are complex complex lines
yeah we should
we should get back to the game position
where none of this might happen who
knows what will happen
yeah
you guys just saw a line I don't even
know how many moves deep was that with
Queen C4 check meeting in the end just
some amazing ideas easy to miss when
you're focused on one side of the board
when you're so concentrated on finding a
mate on the king side with sacrifices
incredibly lying there Fabi just shows
the kind of attacking ideas that do
exist in this position and we see that
now it is time to take that time on the
clock to figure out his way in this very
difficult position which could blow up
with all these lines that we're looking
at also the one thing that I keep
noticing is how the players have really
taken to twirling the piece on in their
hand in these big think moments we know
the champion of that is Boris girlfriend
who we see the top players resort to
that a lot to calm their mind and to
stay completely focused
has a thing in this position trying to
navigate all these possibilities and see
how he can keep things under control we
will go into a shot break and be back
with his decision
producing World quad partner of the
Champions chest tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists it sounds very exciting you
put your skills in practice in a case
competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up World Quant is
seeking new talent and new energy and
it's looking at the world of Chess to
help because nobody knows how to analyze
a position better than a chess player
right no Quan experience no problem
so
do you think you have what it takes to
compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
foreign
hands there for his move 13 of Game 12
of the world championship match he leads
with a one point margin he is a point
and a half away from the ultimate dream
of becoming world champion but playing
with the black pieces today there are
questions to be answered with the
approach that Ding has had in this game
so far and we see their thing has left
the chair Jan is still there having a
big think right now what are the bigger
ones that we've seen burn the clock with
the black pieces their Knight G3 dings
last move the two moves that do come to
mind naturally for Jan in this position
sidestep with the King 2h8 open that g
line for the Rook to come into other
lines that Robert and Fabi have been
discussing also the move F5 blocking
that Bishop on D3 taking control of all
these attacking ideas just consolidating
the position on the king side but the
good news for all of us is that in both
these lines we can potentially see big
peace sacrifices from either of these
two players I'm going to ask Robert
Robert looking at Yan what do you think
is his mindset right now in this
position he can't be too pleased about
getting this kind of a fiery position on
the board in this game 12. no it's going
to require a lot of calculation here
because we saw peace sacrifices from
either side there is a lot to work out
even a forced checkmating sequence that
we were trying to discover was so much
more difficult than the eval bar would
make us believe so I know Chad is busy
Tanya I don't know if you saw this but
during the break I asked them an
important question I said would they
rather play the London in Budapest or
the Budapest in London so I think
they're all busy trying to answer that
question right now they're definitely
busy trying to figure it out for the
question first Robert that's a fun one
well we didn't see a London but we saw a
very quiet opening by Ding and it has
completely exploded Fabi when you start
with the white pieces and you make these
small moves in the opening you play E3
you play C3 we expect it to be a slow
long game but this one is anything but
and we're seeing with all these ideas
the attacking ideas that you're
mentioning the one thing that really got
me by surprise as you mentioned chess is
hard when you've got the best player in
the world well one of the best players
in the world Fabiano caruana struggling
in that position with Robert to see
Queen C4 you know just how difficult and
tricky chess can be so easy to miss well
yeah not missing much he does choose one
of the two options that we were looking
at F5 on the board blocking that Bishop
now the big question will be what does
he have in mind after H3 and the trades
that we're looking at Bobby what do you
make of this decision by Yan
yeah it was I think a 50 50 Choice both
King ghid and F5 were very logical I
don't know if one move is necessarily
better than the other they might be
equivalent choices but in a in a very
uh kind of funny twist
one way would kind of uh encourage black
to sacrifice a piece and the other one
encourages white to sacrifice a piece
although the question will remain after
Bishop 3 Queen F3 is he on a loud Knight
takes a five or does he play that 97
that was leading to those wild
variations that we were looking at where
uh we struggled to find a Checkmate and
to be honest I I'm sure that a lot of
the very the moves that we were checking
there were not at all forced so there
were definitely potential Improvement
improvements for uh both sides in that
variation and I want to look at this
piece sacrifice a little bit more
Bishop F3 Queen F3 if he on decides to
go for king h8 would he be afraid if
Knight takes a five does white even have
to go for Knight H5 because there's also
the move Knight to H5 certainly very
logical
uh in fact let's let's have a look at
Knight H5 because
I don't think we explored this one too
much
and it's the same idea G4 but here black
can let's say after Rook G8 G4 can find
some move that covers F6 Square I think
Queen E7 is a mistake also I know it's
probably not a mistake because Bishop
takes a five is met by Queen to G5
oh wait Queen G5 Bishop D3 and you can't
take the Knight on H5 that's quite funny
oh that's a nice one Fabi
because let's just show that line
and then you just give up your queen but
take the Rook that was actually pinning
the G4 pawn and you end up winning that
Queen so tactics everywhere Queen to d8
or queen D7 queen queen today is a bit
more logical because anyway the queen is
going to go on that diagonal so why
allow Bishop takes a five at all
and
if the king moves somewhere black has
all these like Queen H4 ideas so for
example
King to H1
black can certainly consider starting to
sacrifice material oh wait here you can
already take on G4 and queen H4 so this
is simply bad for white so you have to
move the king to a F1 instead
and
very unclear stuff
I can sacrifice Queen H4
uh G takes a five followed by E5 is is
definitely coming to mind as a very
uh interesting option and
who knows I mean why is it taking just
as many risks as black in all these
lines
you got some decisions by the
H3 was played the Knight on F3 has
indeed been picked up and after Queen F3
will be the big moment does Yan allow
the complications with that Knight
jumping into F5 picking up those three
pawns for the piece in the line that
we've seen now the one question I have
for you Robert in this position is that
after Queen F3 if Yan wants to try to
keep things under control by liquidating
by taking uh by capturing that Knight
which is creating so much trouble for
black queen F3 Bishop takes G3 is that a
capture that actually ends up favoring
dingler in because then we can see a
recapture on that pawn actually pushing
over to G4
yeah we only briefly touched upon it but
it looks really bad for black I don't
think there's any Universe where Jan
would want to do that because if he ever
takes this Knight on G3 and the pawn
will push up to G4 that Springs free the
diagonal the bishop will have new life
and it will cause probably the death of
the black king so I don't think that
after Queen takes F3 uh Jan will be
taking on G3 he will have to allow this
Knight to hop on over to H5 and he'll
live with the consequences the eval Bar
says it's even but I think this is
another moment where we should reiterate
to everybody watching and even to myself
is that players don't have the engines
they don't have the eval bar we only see
the bar going up and down we don't have
the moves they don't even have the bars
they have to rely on their own
assessment and sometimes in positions as
tricky and complicated as this you may
think oh I'm worse when the computer
says you're equal you may think the
position is pretty dynamically balanced
but you're actually losing so it's not
very easy to figure out the exact
evaluation and he does bring his Knight
to E7 so he defends preemptively this
opponent F5 and I do think we're going
to see these crazy variations with
Knight H5 and G4 White's White's most
logical move here is Knight to H5 how
else do you get the attacking because
Queen to H5 will allow Bishop takes G3
you don't want that at all
uh or although you can consider Queen G5
and ig6 fg3 there so I wouldn't say
uh that but Queen H5 just feels a bit
wrong black house will play Knights G6
and and yeah Knight to H5 is really
coming to mind and after Knight to H5
I think King's h8 is the most logical
move
there is Knight to G6 again it's a
position which is rich in options but
King th8 is super logical
and then white has to move Knight to F6
as well as the move G4 that we were
considering
will Yan consider continue to Blitz
because you're just threatening Queen H5
and there's no way to fight that mate on
87 so will black actually have to be
super precise and start offering the
trade with Knight G8 would that be the
way to counter the track
I think so but then it allows Knight
takes D5 the peace sacrifice that he
seemed to have been avoiding
so Knight of 690 and Knight takes D5 is
the same pretty much the same position
now
the Knight magically transported from C6
to
to G8 but besides that a little detail
it's it's the same position but it is an
important transformation because
because they're closer to the black king
which makes the black king feel safer
because
um actually I would like to analyze it
just very quickly to show the difference
because it is an important distinction
and sometimes I think a lot of our
viewers they may say these two lines
look identical how do we tell the
difference well here if this Knight goes
to G8 and we take here we take on F5
we're threatening Checkmate so you have
to stop that with F6 this Knight
actually defends this Pawn on F6 whereas
in the other position the Knight was on
C6 so that Knight is a very important
Defender which means moves like Rook E8
will be possible because you don't need
to be tied down to this Pawn on F6 so
it's a really important distinction a
move like Rook E6 was probably available
with the Knight on C6 with the 99 Rook
E6 you want to double your Rooks but
you're too slow because you're not
threatening this Pawn on F6 so it is
actually a Nuance that would be good for
black and so I don't think we are going
to see a psac in this particular
variation
yeah it's it's really difficult for me
to say because I'm and this is such a
complex position and I even think rookie
E6 here although it it does threaten a
lot less it's still still a viable move
because Rook to E8 I just want to play a
position I want to play uh oh wait it
actually work takes D6
oops just uh training to win on the spot
where Rook takes D6 there as as you
highlighted so how does black plays work
to d8 here I guess to defend that yeah
then I'm just playing with compensation
Rook a to E1
I can't take the pawn D5 but I can
continue in a slow fashion with G3 King
G2 and light squares it's it's all about
those light squares it's
how about that peace
that's nasties
yeah so he played
G4 the line that we were we were looking
at
exactly the same I'm calling out the
game incredible stuff let's go Knight G6
Knight G6 would be such a brave decision
from Jan but this is probably what the
position calls for is instead of just
becoming a turtle and going into your
shell when there are predators around
you you have to fight back and look at
John he's actually about to make a move
very quickly
and he plays Rook G8 so I think that
makes perfect sense that we could see a
transposition because Knight G6 could be
next anyway heading to H4
yeah it's probably very likely to
transpose because well I decides where
to put the king and so we saw that King
to F1 was not working out right just to
reiterate that line King F1 Knight G6
G takes
or at least if y takes on a five which
is not obligatory but let's say can get
H1 let's put that King on a square where
it allows Rook to G1 I'm actually kind
of liking this
or white
and if black continues with Knight G6
Rook to G1
and you jump in with the Knight to H4
hitting your queen I don't know if
that's uh too terrifying because I can
play
Queen to E2
and now can black actually try to just
consolidate on the king side and say no
more open files with the F Pawn push on
F4 is that too dangerous to allow the
bishop to open up on the diagonal
I just realized you have Bishop
too which is kind of annoying
before I was I was happy
F4 I was happy for white because then
you can
you could even
Maybe
I don't know if like F3 makes sense
but
you have Knight of six ideas you have
Queen C2 ideas
I I would really hesitate to play F4
with black because you F3 followed by
Queen F2 it feels like
you're really closing off your play as
well right it's one of those positions
we've talked about this type of style
where maybe the engine says yeah no
reaction it's still equal but you've
limited yourself you've restricted your
own pieces so I think objectively Tony
is the decision is a great one uh but I
think also at the same time it makes
some of the next choices a little bit
more difficult so I understand both of
you here that F4 saves your king because
now you close the position but also
closes off your play and that's the
dynamic question that we are asking here
that if we just pause for a second we've
looked at a variety of options some of
which black is just sort of waiting and
just saying I'm going to defend against
your threat and others is black taking
the initiative himself and being like
let me jump forward and that is actually
a better form of Defense here so I'm
actually surprised that Ding is thinking
after Rook G8 because after G4 bring
your Rook closer to your king pinning
this Pawn on G4 as well seems like a
very natural move
probably the most natural move by Yan
and then ding is doesn't have his
response ready whether to move his King
to the side
yeah Robert before we Deep dive further
into this uh position with all these
tactics the chat has been diving into
your burning question about whether they
should play London in Budapest or the
Budapest in London and I I'm going to
report that the London is the big winner
in this not that much competition there
everyone loves the London I wonder if
that has something to do with the 100
score that London has in the world
championship played only one so far in a
world championship match and it was this
one with the white pieces in game six by
the England which he actually won so
London a good choice thereby Chad Fabi
do you do you approve
I think it's a good opening to play at
any level it's one of those Eternal
openings you know we've we've seen it uh
maybe not at the Forefront of theory
throughout history but it's always been
there as as a viable option and uh then
we had guys who
who are popularizing it a lot obviously
godikamski comes to mind as like one of
the big
um experts and I I would also say
Alexander grishuk comes to mind and even
Magnus uh who who didn't play it as much
as as those other two but Magnus also
had his time when he was playing the
London a ton so we see the the very best
in the world playing the London
succeeding with it at the at the top
level obviously in this match as well
so it's a good opening for any level
whether you're you know uh just starting
out whether you're a very proficient
player whether you're a Grandmaster or
even the best in the world
yeah you're still a professional Fabi
because the question was would you
rather play the London in Budapest so
you have to be in that City or play The
Budapest in London so I feel like people
either are maybe less familiar with
Budapest in the opening but they seem to
want to be in Budapest playing the
London but are they prioritizing the
opening over the city that's my big
question because you've been to both
Budapest and London well I I lived in
Budapest for a little while right and
it's it's a beautiful city
but the the problem with is not the city
the problem is the opening because the
Budapest to remind to remind people you
give away your Pawn on the second move
for absolutely no reason you don't have
to you can play any move you know you
can you can do whatever you want but
some
I guess it was some guy from Budapest
back in the day he was like he was
probably having a few pints and he was
like okay let's let's see what we can do
here on move too let's give our eat one
away for for no reason so that's the
problem with the the question it's not
really the city both cities are amazing
cities of course
yeah well entirely just giving not just
any fun pretty much the most important
Pawn in a Black's position there just
the e-pawn I completely agree with Fabi
there and I think the other thing about
London that has traditionally changed is
that one always used to look at the
opening as super solid where you know
you take out a bishop on F4 you're
playing E3 C3 you take out your knight
on D2 but over time there are all these
other options where you can go for the
jababa London you can also play H4 at
some point so you can decide if you want
to have the traditional positional
approach of the London or create more
Dynamic chances make it an attacking
fight so it's just a very flexible
opening and especially in faster time
controls we see it becoming more and
more popular meanwhile doing goes with
your idea of of playing the move King to
H1 it is on the board he's the one with
head in hands right now slightly
surprised because it's not his mood but
he's clearly trying to think about what
happens after the natural looking knight
G6 it's also a move that's being that's
screaming to be played You're simply
bringing that Knight to H4 hitting that
Queen on F3 I love that line and I would
love it if you deep dive a little bit
into it and we see yeah she has left his
resting area and is about to walk back
into the playing Arena has he made his
choice already while he was in the rest
area or will he take a little bit of his
time to make the move Knight G6 but
apart from that do we see an alternative
here for black
yeah absolutely there's a move Rook to
G5 it's also very logical
uh the thing is I'm not sure if after
Rook G5 Rook to G1 this is helping
Black's cause because I could see The
Rook trade being a lot of danger for
black like Rook G1 let's say other Rook
to G8
um
yeah and if like Rook a to G8 I think G
takes a five could start to be very
dangerous for black here
because it's just a few
yeah if you take out on F5 with the
Knight then I can take on F5 with the
bishop right
potentially
and if you take with the Rook I take on
G8
is a king escape this king is escaping
to the center though that's Queen G4
king of Fate I thought it would be
dangerous but
um maybe it leads absolutely nowhere for
white so white would have to find
something better than this
you know maybe the problem is after Rook
G1 Rook G8 there's like a knight F6 to
throw in because your Rook can't easily
move up I have Knight E8 ideas in some
of these positions and there's tactics
Galore at this point
yeah 98 is a crucial idea also after
Rook G6 I'm wondering is it 98 or is
there there's also this move H4 very
tempting
H4 allows Rook to H6
what a crazy position this this is crazy
stuff but at the very least white white
can probably play Knight T8 here and and
probably
I mean D7 it's not clear if this is
leading to an advantage so take take
maybe just a positional Advantage some
Rook G3 followed by Rook to G1 and
flame uh I'm slightly better
old claim Fabi bold claim
who knows I mean
it looks okay to the naked eye
this should be an exciting option but
the one that Janus chosen equally
exciting and equally fun we have been
talking about this line with potential
night jumps a knight G6 has been the
move of choice Diana Pharmacy he's
looking at bringing that Knight to H4
and now once again it is on thing you
can't fight that threat the Knight is
arriving on H4 regardless of the move
that you make Rook G1 the most natural
response to this move
it's very it's very natural Rook G1
Knight H4 followed by Queen D2 is super
logical it allows that Bishop H2 I don't
know if that's uh just to remind the
viewers because it's been a while since
we mentioned this line but we did
actually look at this line quite far in
advance after G takes a five which is
probably a very serious mistake and we
can like quickly run down that line
again because I think it was quite fun
Knight to H4 Queen to E3 Rook to G2
Queen to H6
trending Checkmate so it's even though
the computer says it loses it's not at
all obvious why so Rook to H2 King to G1
Rook to GA King to F1 again white is
threatening checkmate with Queen F6 but
black saves the I think only in one way
like we or maybe black saves a day in
more than one way but
um but yeah this bishop to E7 F6 and now
Knight to F5 Bishop takes a five and
suddenly out of the blue
uh wise writing Checkmate again but
Queen to C4 rookie two rookie Jordan
checkmate
uh
out of the blue a Checkmate along the
diagonal even the queen coming to C4
so we won't see this but it's it's fun
to show it anyway
super hard to spot even in the moment we
struggled with it uh for a bit there so
it's even more difficult to visualize
that type of position you could see that
you have an attack so I feel like Jan he
knows when uh how to play he's whether
he's the initiative that is he's
obviously a very intuitive player with
great calculation skills so I feel like
he understands this Knight coming to H4
is very dangerous for the white King on
H1 so I think Rook G1 that feels like a
very safe option relatively speaking you
keep the tension between these pawns and
yeah I do think that this game will just
continue and both sides will have their
chances to take control to gain the
upper hand but I like the way that this
is going the direction of the game is
good for dingly Ren he needs to get a
win and this definitely gives him
chances
but this line that we've been looking at
and I'm just uh I just want to ask you
one question on it because it just looks
like black is finishing the game off
with a checkmate was there a possibility
at some point for white to actually
throw in a check on F6 and make sure you
don't get your other Rook into the
attack witch yet because there's a big
there's a big chance of ding actually
going for this uh this option of trying
to get that Queen to eight six of trying
to get that Knight to F6 you're
basically threatening a mate in one and
if you see a way to counter Black's
attack then that is super tempting to go
into so Robert if you don't mind can we
just Deep dive into that just a little
more pull up the analysis board just for
a moment and take a look at this option
or is this uh is this a bad idea for
ding to get into sorry can you repeat
the line that you're so you take on F5
E3
yes
and now Queen it's six right so this is
very important and this was the point
that I just wanted to make Robert that
it's so crucial for black to actually
not spend time to take the F5 Pawn
because if you just back up for a second
instead of Rook G2 if you waste time
with a move like GTA e takes F5 then
white actually isn't time to come in
with the attack Queen 86
Rook G2 and now nothing works out for
black because you've got to check on F6
and the bar approves and I think Rook G1
is the follow-up the night falls as well
so you really have to go for the attack
with Rook G2 what are the chances for
ding to actually miss this idea of Queen
C4 in the end because
then I think that you might just go for
this attack I think that
um in fact e-tex F5 the movie we
mentioned is is actually very good and a
much simpler maybe Rook G2 is good but
he takes a five and the point is after
Queen six we aren't going with the
attack immediately because we have Rook
to G6 and that actually just kills all
the play and I think that's what once
you see this Rook G6 you just stop your
calculation with white and with black
because you realize he takes a five
whites attack is actually going nowhere
and you're left probably with your king
going to be uh getting hunted down
rather than the other way around
so with that in mind I think
we Although our line was fun it was it's
always nice to to get into his fantasy
variations but
he takes e takes A5 is a cold shower
and yeah once you mentioned I I saw that
like this queen H6 is actually a dead
end for white so white thing will not go
for this I'm I'm completely sure at this
point that there's no temptation even to
go for that
so father you mentioned a different line
with Knight H uh with sorry Rook G1
Knight H4 and if Queen E2 there was like
some Bishop H2 stuff because you're
kicking this Rook away so this looks
pretty annoying for white to deal with
your Rook can't go up to G2 the Knight
will take it if the Rook goes up to G
wait a sec
I was about to say you you know what
that happens when you're speaking you
can't do this and I'm wondering now what
if you do sacrifice an exchange like
this
it's a really interesting idea because
the Knight should drop back to G6 and uh
it's not a matter of like some direct
tactics I think it's just you're taking
the pawn
so G takes F5 he takes F5
and
I guess you could take on F5 immediately
or queen F3 it's it's hard to say
what first because those pawns are
dropping off one way or the other but
let's say Bishop takes F5
Rook let's say ate eight
Queen to F3
we already see like a natural move like
Rook T8 the computers
doubting a little bit but yeah white
just has a lot of compensation upon for
the exchanges already not that much
material down Knight on H5 beautiful
coming to F6 Bishop very strong blacks
Knight on G6 and not really in the game
anymore in terms of attacking still a
defensive piece but
yeah super interesting this Rook G3
it was an accident I was just trying to
illustrate for everybody because
sometimes we go a little bit too quickly
and I was like okay after Bishop H2 here
this Rook can't stay on the G file it
really wants to remain here to challenge
the black Rook Rook G2 you're gonna see
the eval bar plummet because Knight
takes G2 this is very clear and I was
just trying to indicate that you can't
make the move and then I'm saying it out
loud I'm like wait a second this is
actually kind of funny so uh it was an
accident but it was a happy accident
yeah that's a Grand Master Level move
that's a super Grand Master Level move
to me Rook G3 just feels like a move
that you wouldn't even consider you know
you're just basically saying take my
Rook for your strong Bishop I would be
amazed to see ding to go for this for me
the more natural the bishop H2 would be
Simply sidestep Save Your material it's
an important game you're gonna need that
Rook for the attack move it to F1 move
it to E1 any other Square Robert which
is give it for free voluntarily on G3
such a great resource and once again
shows the kind of sacrifices that do
exist in chess where it's not just about
sacrificing for attack but taking away
your opponent's strongest piece super
instructive stuff here
and I just want to give a shout out to
the featured chat by it looks like doe
wit if I mispronounce that my apologies
but this feels like a report game and
not a typical ding game with the offbeat
opening and the wild tactic so fubby you
have by far the most experience against
all these players would you agree with
that chat comment
yeah well Richard definitely
tends to get into some wild stuff more
so than we would associate with
dangaforce I first played so Richard was
born I think in 1996. correct me if I'm
wrong there but we first played in 2010
and he was he was a little kid I was
also a kid but he was uh he was still
like not even I think he was a
Grandmaster so he was a prodigy but that
was one of the craziest games I've ever
had and I remember it pretty much from
beginning to end I don't know why it was
so memorable it was a draw but it lasted
like 100 moves it was a team event
Hungary against Italy at the time I was
playing for Italy and uh at the end all
the players were crowded around this
this board which was
um going in like deep into the end game
and yeah
Richie has has always been
uh such a fascinating player of course
now he's not a kid anymore he's a top
Grand Master
and the second of dingley Ren but yeah
we could have easily seen this in in
some some Richie game right we can
speculate on the inspiration that he's
given ding to to play some of these
creative
um you know openings like the colay or
or the London system
Mission his opening ideas the kind of
dynamic middle games that we're seeing
from thing and as you mentioned well
stylistically we know a thing to be an
absolute beast in these positional
strategic fights but he's been so much
more open to playing these kind of
setups which do demand tactical
precision as well and it's always been
fascinating the role of seconds in these
matters and I'm thinking about the 21
world championship match Yan versus uh
Magnus where it was Peter leko who was
Jan's second and we saw such a big shift
in Yan style in that match where he was
sort of not sticking to his usual
aggressive options that he would
intuitively be more inclined to take on
the board but a more positional approach
do you think Fabi in these matches
spending months with your trainer months
with your seconds team uh in preparation
it's not just the opening but also your
style of play that gets influenced
yeah I think definitely whoever you're
working with they they could easily have
an effect on your on how you view chess
how you approach chess it might not
change your style because
uh obviously these guys have been
playing chess for so long and you know
it's not like they're being formed right
they're they've already been formed as
players
uh although you continue to learn things
even if you're a top Grandmaster like
yawn or like ding you continue to learn
and evolve your chests in in some ways
so for sure I mean if if they're working
with let's say it's Richard report or
the it's Peter laco they're doing so
because they have something that they
could potentially learn from these guys
and so that could it might not lead to
drastic changes but it will definitely
lead to their difference in their
understanding of certain positions uh
how they view certain openings and these
sorts of things
yeah I wouldn't be surprised at all if
working with Richie has inspired thing
to uh
let's say it's a change at least his
opening approach to evolving in some way
how he's trying to approach chess
and indeed we are seeing inspired play
in Game 12 of the world championship
Matt ding plays his one of the two final
whites in the match he needs to find a
way to win a game to equalize currently
on move 19 ding having a thing in a
complicated position this this game is
going to be extremely entertaining do
not go anywhere we will be back after a
shot break
we have Magnus Carlson's most incredible
moments as world champion this one right
here is vishwanathan with the white
pieces versus Magnus Carlson in 2013.
here we go so this is uh Nims on Indian
Samus variation right and the last move
here was B3 from Magnus just saying hey
man I'm trying to Queen this pawn and of
course Anan is saying I'm trying to
Major King cool you can get your little
queen I'm just going to try to Checkmate
you right so of course this is a hints
to move at five B3 and he's like cool oh
fish one to the non says hey okay you
can get this queen I'm going to try to
go for me so he goes Queen F4 you get
another piece in the game this looks
very very dangerous here nice C7 what
the heck is going on night to see
somebody thought it'd be something
spectacular he was like yeah I'm waiting
for this one but it's just Knight to C7
defensive move cool allows F6 to happen
here
F6 is going to take on G7 it's going to
be kind of annoying scary things
happening with Knight H5 Magnus plays G6
okay it's locked up it's gonna be scary
if a queen gets to H6 also if the queen
in a rook get to the H file it's gonna
be a wrap for black here Magnus is going
to be mated Okay cool so Magnus
understands that Vichy announced as
understands that too and plays Queen to
H4 where is he going class
eight six right he's about to make he's
also trying to get the Rook over here
too as well okay cool with that being
said your move what do you do now it's
black to move
here's the move hence Knight C7 to put
the Knight on EA the saying goes a night
on E8 is actually f8 the x is what they
say there is no mate a knight
understands this he said oh there's no
mermaid that's cool I'm gonna put my
queen right here what I'm trying to do
is bring the Rook up to F3 or F4 and
actually go for this manual H7 because
you stop the G7 mate that's cool perfect
well Magnus understands this so what
does Magnus do in this position like to
move
here it is Magnus says cool you want
mate
that's cool that's cool go for it B2 do
your thing big fella go ahead
wanted on so he says okay I will young
fella Rook F4 he goes here and he's
going for Rook H for me wow is this
scary why are you gonna get your queen
you did all of this are you gonna get
your queen or not
of course we are B1 Queen right after B1
Queen Knight to F1 from Hanan and the
move the move here that seals the deal
is what guys there's two Queens on the
board Magnus has two queens but is he
getting mated or not it's black to move
he goes
Queen E1 and then the game is over
ah the game ended right here believe it
or not there is no more PGN right what
do you mean Queenie what how what what
what what sense does that make well
let's see what happens the idea here you
have the queen E1 where were you putting
your Rook H4 well I can just go Rook H4
but guess what after I capture it Queen
sacrifice sacrificing one of my two
queens after Queen takes H4 let's do a
peace count you have a queen you have a
bishop and a knight I have a queen a
bishop a knight and a rook guys so after
that this is done right I have an extra
piece an extra rook and there's no mate
here so that's a resignation and Magnus
wins that's incredible right
oh
[Music]
Robert we do see Yan taking his time
right now perhaps not one of the moves
that he was expecting
question mark on the board our eval Bar
says that white
made an inaccuracy here what's going on
why is Bishop C2 been awarded the
question mark right now
yeah it's sometimes feels unfair in
chess when you go to game analysis game
review and you're like well I thought I
made a good move why am I getting a
question mark but this was a mistake you
could just see the evil bar I'll just go
a half step back you see it was towards
the center then after the bishop C2 all
of a sudden black is the side for choice
and we understand why ding would make
this move Bishop C2 opens up the D3
square if you want to line up this
battery and go for an eventual
checkmating attack so there is Merit to
this move Bishop to C2 and it's not the
worst mistake right it wasn't a blunder
but you see how quickly Jan just brought
his Knight up to H4 the best decision
this queen has to move and in many of
the variations we looked at before that
resulted in a Checkmate it was important
that this queen got to C4 when the King
was on F1 now that looks even more
available to the black queen and also
black can simply go Rook G6 bring this
Rook over to Jade I feel like time is
very important here and playing Bishop
C2 two it seems like a bit of a waste of
time
yeah this is a interesting moment Bishop
C2 definitely doesn't come to mind
immediately but I think it was because
he was looking at Rook G1 Knight H4 he
wants to put the queen on E3 to play
potentially Queen H6 then he saw that F4
is where he is kicking the queen away
and so he amended that whole concept by
playing Bishop C2 Queen either end of f4
Queen D3 and now you threaten made on H7
uh still the computer does not like what
at all here is it because Rook G6 simply
could just be Rook G6 Rook G8 followed
by F5
and
I mean all these lines Fabby who is
attacking who is the first question I
want to ask you
well I don't see why it's attacked
whatsoever
like I I just don't see how you ever get
to the H7 Pawn so
I think if white is doing okay it's
because he has like some very slow long
term plan
I think in this kind of position you
probably want to play F3 at some moment
because I'm very worried to be allowing
like Rook G8 and your queen can't move
because Knight F3
I just want to play like F3 rookie 2 to
kind of lift
lift The Rook into the fence so I can
play rookie 2 followed by
maybe work to G1 at some point
but I'm also super worried that I'm
cutting off access to the king side so
if at some point Black's pieces get in
there
could be you know checkmates on the H
file could be all sorts of potential
attacking ideas
like Queen E7 Knight F5 and queen H4 and
just you know you throw everything at
your king you sacrifice pieces I don't
know
um yeah
definitely not not exactly here but like
if if like I've worked to G8 here and
then Knight to F5 take Queen h40 like
you could start to see some
some potential things like this working
out right
in this case it actually does seem to
work out engine approved yeah so you
give up all your pieces over here but
this king is the one that's in Creative
danger well let's show the end of that
line Queen to F1 instead of fg6
okay
we'd have one Rook G1
Queen G1 Queen H3
Queen H2 Queen F3 and Checkmate on G2
so you can't you can't defend against
the threats
just can't do it
is didn't get in serious Danger
and also notice how when Yan thinks for
a while on a move the next one he often
makes it really fast it's like he's seen
a line and then he goes for it now this
move that thing played the bishop
Retreat he took a while for it and
Knight H4 is of course the first
response that you look at uh it's the
most direct move it's the one that
threatens the queen and now once again
we see ding slowing down the doubts on
that calculation the second guessing of
his own moves is this something that is
surprising and apart from Queen E3 that
you're pointing out Queen D3 is the
other natural move that comes to mind
can you guys highlight the differences
between these two and is it more
beneficial for white to not provoke F4
perhaps
yeah I guess I'll take the lead here and
Bobby uh you can back me up or find
better but if Queen D3 stops this Pawn
from moving that was telling his whole
point of the question because if this
Pawn were to move then there's Queen
takes H7 Checkmate that was the whole
point of bringing the queen and Bishop
on the same diagonal forming the battery
that would be made to this black king
but F4 is out of the question I still
think that black can play this the way
that we've been talking about like why
not play Rook G6 I don't think all that
much has really changed because after
Rook G8 things like this at some point
we could still push this Pawn as The
Rook blocks this queen and bishop's pass
on the diagonal this looks really
Troublesome for dingly rent I feel like
telling you made an excellent point that
when janapomsi thinks he often follows
it up very quickly he's in the flow of
the game I like the way he's playing
whereas ding he goes for a thing then a
move is played then he goes for another
thing I just feel like Jan has the
initiative now in the upper hand
Queen E3 played
yeah I think that he provokes F4 with
good reason because in those lines
as Robert mentioned after Queen D3 black
doesn't move the F Pawn yet but plays
over to G6 first and I think that after
black puts other work on G8 a very
critical idea would be to take on G4 and
followed up with the F5 and White's King
is really the one that is more
vulnerable than blacks because there's
no H Pawn to cover it from potential
things on the H file like fruit G2 Rook
H2
Flex pieces are just attacking more
efficiently than whites are
and
so he wants to prepare F4 at least it
keeps uh he wants to provoke F4 that is
at least it keeps the position closed
and
black does still have Rook G6 here I am
kind of wondering about this move
because if G takes a five there's always
you always have to watch out for Rook to
G2 as well
I think maybe in this case it's already
a bit too late to be watching out
because you've
Queen H6 we've seen like the tip the the
same idea already here here's much
easier between six Rook H2 King G1 Rook
G8 King F1 Queen C4 because the bishop
went to C2 right so
the visual doesn't even have to be
distracted from that diagonal but the
before black uh
as this checkmate
so Rook G6 is also I suspect that Eon
might consider his option a bit here
because both F4 and Road G6 are very
tempting options
maybe white needs to play this like four
Define F3
again
doesn't look good though right I mean
what is do you have white two free moves
besides let's go Pac-Man and eat all the
pieces if we gave ideas more so than
moves what is White's idea in the
position I don't think you ever want to
take on F5 that opens the G file
especially with the Rook coming over
here so what's the plan that dingley
Wren is trying to make work
that's a great question Robert
that's not a great question because I
can answer it it's a great question
because I can't answer it
I just don't see White's idea here I
mean
slowly get C4 but you don't even know if
you want to get C4 and it would take
like a million moves anyway so prepare
B3 C4 and so on
so I guess your idea is rookie two
green F2
but then just Queen E7 defends it
for Queen d8 so that doesn't really
change anything
F4 followed by G5
maybe but then H6 will kind of open
things up
a bit concerned
maybe you have no ideas you just say I'm
not winning this game anymore
but I'll try not to lose it and I'll
I'll still hold this position together
and wait for black to try to break
through
that's not the best case scenario for
dingler and at all given the math
situation Fabi but maybe things have
gone wrong and backfired in this uh
attack that Ding was looking for on the
king's side now F3 to consolidate the
king side also has its own drawbacks of
creating these dark Squad weaknesses I
want to ask you instead is there another
approach that perhaps they can be
thinking about uh in these lines with
Rook to G6 maybe just slide his own Rook
to G1 and start offering Rook trades on
the G line is that something that Ding
can be looking at
I think so my concern was that like
let's say Rook to G6 Rook 2 on Rook G8
let's make those those moves and let's
just consider if if white takes on F5
and maybe Rook to G2 is still a concern
Ed
it's a meeting one yeah
you have to trade that Rook G2 Rook G2
but Rook H2 is no longer a critical
threat because black doesn't have that
second Rook to get into the attack
so maybe white can play like fe6
nope
I I just want to point out I almost fell
for a Checkmate that trying to get the
queen to eight six and there is a
Checkmate in fact with a rook check on
H2 the Knight jumping to F3 after the
king moves to G1 and what we were
pointing out that moved by ding of the
bishop Retreat and suddenly the queen
comes to C4 with the check and this
would be game over so easy to fall for
these tactics
yeah this this is showing why Bishop C2
was
was not really a great move because the
bishop is actually more of a defense a
better defensive piece on D3
and although ding did have an idea and
it makes sense in a vacuum but in this
specific position it just doesn't meet
the demands of the position
but still that yeah that's an option
Rook G1 followed by G5 at least it's a
very
concrete option that I think ding will
be looking for concrete ways to solve
his problems
the other issue I think though is let's
say let's try that again Rook G6 Rook G1
Rook G8 and G takes F5
super direct approach boy I'm wondering
what if I just play e takes if I with
black
like yeah you
are just better here
oh Rook takes G6 followed by Knight F6
is
what are you capturing with
me
it's very dangerous because suddenly
there's Queenie Aid ideas on the table
so here I'm like very worried
there's even okay just Rook G1 maybe
it's simple enough
and the queen eight is a deadly threat
really looks like it's like pressure is
on for white uh Robert do you think Jan
taking his time Spidey senses tingling
here for him makes a move well it's for
Rook G6 so we might be seeing these
lines yes sir what was that about Yan
taking his time he was didn't even allow
you to finish your sentence because he
said I have this one under control he's
making very logical moves he's making
very good moves and it is confusing
Bishop C2 by ding in this one we've had
some confusing light Square Bishop moves
yawn in the opening played Bishop D7 we
kind of were scratching our heads trying
to come up with a reason why and then
here dink brought his Bishop to C2 so he
may have had a point but this is not
going to lead him to the full point that
he needs I'm looking at this position I
really like Black's chances I'm seeing
doubling of the Rooks
y'all can start thinking about taking
this match here and now if he wins the
game the match isn't officially over but
then ding would have to win both game 13
and 14 just to send to tie breaks John's
position is good he's up on the clock
there's 20 moves left to make until they
reach the time control and this is a
hectic position so the moves will not be
easy and we've seen ding in time trouble
in this match it hasn't been
particularly good for him
oh my God Fabi is it the time when Jan
starts getting ambitious with black
right now
oh absolutely but um so I was just gonna
say Rook to G1
let's let's say immediately
it's sort of inviting Bishop H2 maybe
ding will think I invite Bishop H2 I
play Rook G to F1
what loses
you know Wi-Fi Rook G3 oh we already saw
this idea but it's even worse because
the Knight doesn't have a retreat Square
that's hilarious you cut off circulation
between Queen and Bishop and then once
it takes after Pawn takes the Knight is
just trapped I forgot I forgot your idea
yeah it works here far more effectively
it was it was effective there but even
more effectively here where it just wins
the game okay it's a little trap it's
it's kind of uh it's a seductive trap
it would so what's the problem with Rook
G1 because Rook GA we saw GTX 5 is is
kind of unclear a bit of a mess that
would have to be calculated but
wasn't clear-cut at all so what's the
issue with this logical move Rook to G1
is it F4 followed by Rook to H6
between D3 Rook H6 it's not easy to do
something like this well you could also
play Rook to G8 now right
yeah I guess so that's that's true
well let's say does the Queen have
another Square let's say queen to E2
but now the group can also go to G5 as
well
the H6 is it's kind of it protects
against it against any like Queen H7
threats and
that H file is is scary I'm seeing some
exchange sacks in the future
I've seen some Knight of five ideas like
Rook H6 F3 at some point Knight F5 you
know
fall
Fabio I got something it's kind of G5
because if you play F3 can I sack my
queen and after you take my queen of
Rook G7 I'm trying to mate you
you're um
[Laughter]
it's a fascinating idea
I'd like to F5 like you take a knight of
six and that actually is checkmate
exactly that was my whole this is the
ridiculous Checkmate but
um oh wait what's the defense then is it
just a five three sacking the queen no
don't do that are you kidding me
it's a it's a Duo F5 Rook C7 Bishop C7
rookie one
wait it's not this apparently but still
oh because I thought it was G8
Knight F3 rookie two Rook GA but there's
Knight to G7
it's actually important
otherwise black just wins this position
but Knight G7 stops the Checkmate oh my
gosh that's
spawn on H6 is a hero because you just
try to turn the tables on me you slide
dog you were trying to make me I tried
to mate you first
oh that's very that's very funny so what
was the reputation of this variation
you know really I'm very you know I'm
composed like yeah I don't start
cracking up mid broadcaster that was
quite funny uh I don't know what the
refutation is because that looks scary
yeah it is it is very scary it's it's
not the thing that you would immediately
say oh black wins you would you would
say maybe black wins but first let me
um
let me you know cry a little bit inside
that I'm getting mated and then
eventually I'll find the
maybe I'll find the defense what is the
defense I have no idea
zero clue
we do have a move so we will be finding
out what
has been kids or all these lines might
be appearing with a mids in one counter
checkmates in one there is so much at
stake in this game if janapamnashi with
the chances that he's been given and we
see the eval bar going in his favor does
indeed win today essentially that would
mean match over a two-point deficit
Robert as you pointed out ding will have
to win with the black pieces the next
game and with the white piece is the
final game a task that sounds impossible
to accomplish with all this at stake of
course for the two players it is the
biggest stage of their lives the biggest
match of their lives and at the end of
it we will have a new world champion we
will have a world champion who's not
called Magnus Carlsen after 10 years
after a decade 2013 was when Magnus won
the match and after that 2023 is when
we'll have our 17th world champion and
these are definitely thoughts that are
in Yan's mind given the position that
has been created Rook G1 we've been
talking about balancing the act of
creating us on the board but also making
sure that it doesn't backfire for ding
is it safe to say that Ding is on the
defense here right now Robert
yeah I think it appears that way but
based on what we were just looking at I
could see young going wrong I I still
don't know what the solution was there
Fabi I see you uh I'm excited I found it
I found it you found it
I'll let you I'll you know we'll bring
up announcement show but I just want to
say very quickly that it looks like
there's a fun line we're just laughing
but it actually is an extremely
important variation because F4 is a very
logical move hitting the queen and we're
talking about Queen D3 doesn't threaten
anything you're stepping in front of the
bishop which is attacking The Rook so
Queen E2 does make sense and Rook H6
makes sense because you're it's
protecting the square in front of your
king which was vulnerable and in some
positions threatening this Knight but
after G5 this Rook is in trouble it's
trapped so F3 is forced I'm giving up my
queen to go for checkmate so Fabi how in
the world were you stopping this check I
think I I think there's only one move I
think it's Bishop to E5
I really hope I'm not getting this one
wrong
because Rook takes H7 King to G8 wait oh
my god do it I need to see it's right
right yeah King G8 and now the bishop
defends all the stuff like if you were
trying to defend the F6 Square via let's
say Bishop to E7 then white would have
this Rook G7 followed by H7
uh let's say Bishop B7 here Rook takes
H7 King G8 and at least Rook G7 and okay
King J draw and King f8 H7 and white
promotes
um yeah we see that that that's winning
but Bishop B5 defends Against The Rook
G7 and then after uh let's say Rook H7
King G8 take only five Queen E5
the other point is that the queen not
only is defensive but also friends E1
Queen so now Rook to G7 I can just play
King death eight and uh and now I'm a
queen and E1 Queen is is a deadly threat
as well so it's not just like H7 here
okay probably has a bunch of problems
but at the very least E1 coming right
so Bishop to E5 it I I don't I didn't
see any other moves I think it's the
only only real way to do to win the game
but Bobby Bishop E5 is the only way to
win or maybe there is something else but
it's hard enough to see it in this
position but you'd have to visualize
this in advance and find Bishop E5
because this looks close to losing for
black in many of these positions with
White's attack raging on all these
mating Nets configurations here against
this King so I feel like for yawn this
could be a really scary thing to see in
your head when you don't have the exact
answer you don't know for sure that it's
minus four and change you think okay
this looks scary for my king I don't
want to go for this
yeah absolutely I I think what would be
uh a relief for him is that he did have
like this F5 move like he wasn't risking
in this line it's only that there was
one way to win but probably F5 is
leading to some sort of equality
um and even we saw like Bishop to E7 the
engine was saying that some sort of draw
although you are kind of terrified to
play Bishop B7 because
um because you could also lose right
it's it's not
for a human you might easily think that
white is checkmateans about here so
super super uh scary looking stuff I
mean amazing amazing find by you there
uh as as let's say a practical try
we have a move
we haven't moved f4 on the board so we
could be headed in these these
directions that you bought are pointing
out with these check mating ideas Jana
promise how far has he calculated
hitting that Queen right now Queen E2 is
one of the moves that you were looking
at Ken white also think about maybe
sidestepping to D3 a big moment for ding
he's definitely feeling the heat right
now and once again Robert is such a big
moment in the Chess World regardless of
who wins the world championship it will
be indeed an end of an era
yes because at the end of this match we
will have a new world champion Magnus
Carlson has been the world champion
since 2013. he's been the highest rated
player in the world for even two years
before that so uh for Magnus he has to
hand that Crown over he didn't do it in
a match he has not lost a match but he
has abdicated the throne and it is
looking like Janda Palm she is ready to
pick up the mantle to take home that
title to become the new world champion
but dingly Wren you know is he able to
dig deep that's the big question right
now because it has been a true brawl in
this world championship match and for
ding it started early in game two he
lost the white pieces but then he was
able to strike back he's proven that
throughout this match when he goes down
by a point he has been able to even up
the scoreboard but right now this looks
like a determined yonda Palm she
throughout this game he played a weird
opening but right now he is not In
Harm's Way in fact it looks like dingley
Wren is the one who needs to find a way
just to salvage some sort of equality
yeah
yeah and look at the level bar it is
inching towards Jan so he is in driving
seat this is his big opportunity to
actually close the match today if he
continues to play uh accurately in this
position but again it is a position for
all three results where draw is the
least likely outcome uh Fabi how scary
is this looking for Ding and how big is
this a moment for Yan to actually just
shut down the match and get that second
Victory we also have a move by ding he
has made the move Queen to D3
yeah I think it's a really scary moment
uh I mean why doesn't a great deal of
danger here and Black's moves flow very
naturally I think that Rook to G8 could
easily come on the board quickly
and
white still has to prove that the plan
or wait worksheet allows Knight to F6 I
just realized so maybe that move does
not is not actually effective at all
because it would probably Force black to
play something like Rook to f8 losing
time
so he puts he's playing so quickly Queen
to E7
he didn't even take a moment on the
board he just comes back makes the move
Queen E7 he's really putting the
pressure on on ding on the board and the
clock and I want to ask you Fabi before
you deep dive into it how much of this
narrative is because of Yan's match
experience in the world championship
I think this is yawn's natural style
he's he's intuitive he's
um going back to what he used to do very
often which is which is Play instant
moves sometimes he would backfire for
him but here I think that he can afford
to do so because he has control over the
position I am wondering about a very
sharp option for white here it's very
double-edged could could easily backfire
to move G5
we said what is White's plan well white
doesn't really have a clear plan but
white does have a temporary moment to
Break Free with the move G5 followed by
Rook to G4 Rook G1 Knight F6 ideas and
you can't take that pawn
the question for me is after Knight to
F5 are you losing that pawn and it
wasn't 100 clear to me because there's
Knight to F6 here
and we do in fact see
that Knight F5 is a serious mistake
and Peter hates every move that I make
even though
like they're not
oh wait is Knight of five H4 good like
they're not obviously bad to me I mean
with the Knight on an H5 maybe H4 was
strong
six
um yes H4 is the reason but after 94 I
still don't see it it's
because Queen to H3 allows Rook takes G5
so fabi's point is that the queen
defends the Knight so if you take what
looks like a free piece Rook takes G1 is
check the Rook gets out the way that
means the queen would be lost so okay so
it's probably Knight to F6 after Knight
H4 Knight F6 followed by Queen H3 next
[Laughter]
yeah I give up too no don't worry fubby
uh I have no clue
[Music]
um
it could be Rook G4 Knight if I Rook G1
but
yeah the the bar is
is teasing me
like this does not look necessarily bad
for black but uh
but it could could potentially be
yeah I guess Rook G8 there's Knight F6
so you yeah but there's cortex F6 there
I mean it's very sharp Queen takes up
six as an option oh wow
and then Rook H6 King G2 Rook G4
and King to F1
oh my goodness
still okay I guess why this is now
completely out of danger but still
remains kind of complex
yeah I guess the point is that after
Queen Rook F6 is Queen B5 things like
that you'll go after the queen side
pawns because black does have a knight a
rook and a couple pawns for the queen
that's quite a lot of material uh but
there's play on two flanks and
unfortunately black is not prepared to
deal with some of this queen side
pressure I I'm with you Fabi I see what
the eval bar is doing it's rejecting
some of our moves sure but it just goes
to show how complicated this position is
because I see the evil bar saying white
is better I wouldn't be surprised if you
had you super gems play this position
out in like you know a thousand games if
black actually wins a healthy percentage
of the time because Black's King is way
safer black has just more pieces on the
board you have some pawns that can go
forward some Rook checks this actually
is quite Dynamic so I don't really care
what the eval Bar says I know that
neither side is lost but I feel like
it's a very very tricky position
yeah this is some crazy stuff uh of
course none of these moves that we made
were forced and some of them were
certainly mistakes but stuff like this
uh definitely running through the
calculations of both players because
I think G5 is a very natural
straightforward move and we saw Knight
F5 is not the response but that does beg
the question what is the response to G5
I think it's a very very critical uh
and we don't see him play it but it
seemed to me like a critical option
makes another natural move while G5 a
critical option but perhaps
it comes out to keep the pawns intact on
the king king side it brings the final
piece the final toy into the nursery
with the move rookie one placing it on
the e-file and I want to ask you guys
and understand this yes we see the eval
bar give Yan an advantage but let's say
Yan did have a couple of moves how does
he really build on it what is progress
for black in this position if white was
not to take middle decisions like the
one you mentioned Fabi with G5
I think one natural way of playing is
Rook G8 followed by Rook to H6
we want to get that Rook out of The
Bishop's way on C2 and either H file and
after that we can consider Queen G5 and
just like slowly build up the pressure
on the
it's not like we have immediate threats
but we'll maybe we'll play F3 there
maybe we'll play F5 and
white is not going to have fun waiting
around waiting for the Breakthrough so
you you just build up Souls you're not
gonna you don't have immediate Knockouts
here right white is still relatively
solid
but the slow buildup of pressure could
be extremely dangerous Rook to H6 or
Rook to G8 here both moves
in fact also Queen to G5 is very logical
as well Queen G5 allows Queen B5
probably
uh probably not something
you want to allow just yet
so Rook to H6
oh wait does Rook H6 still allow uh
Knight F6 just
oh I don't know
you're a tricky man I'm just going to
quickly show that Knight F6 Bobby's
saying because if you take with the Rook
you got checkmated in one move it's a
distraction tactic and if you take with
the queen it becomes a fork you lure the
queen to the F6 that is sick man Knight
F6 out of nowhere yeah that's a
surprising tactic but it seems to work
out
so Rook to G8 first
to stop that threat because then after
Knight to F6
like if Rook H6 then Knight F6 black
would have the Rook takes G5 resource in
the end let's say A3 Rook H6 Knight F6
queen of six but I'm wondering is there
your G5 move now
yeah definitely G5 it's it's always an
option
and I was thinking in another position
maybe H6 was an option but here
H6 is maybe not as effective
also because there's simply Knight to F6
again right
times six and then Knight takes D5
tactics and all sorts of
messy things are happening here
Bobby all these lines that you're
showing
Queen into the attack why can't Yan
start doing it now stopping this counter
play of white with the move G5 start
with the move Queen G5 and as I said it
Yan responds yes that's the way to go he
does play the move Queen G5 but your
ideas of Rook G at Rook 86 coming up
next and that would be extreme pressure
now white doesn't have the option to
create play on the king side with the
move G5 it's pressure on the board
pressure on the clock as well for ding
17 moves to be made 42 minutes for ding
how much of a factor is that going to be
Robert
oh it's a huge Factor because this
position is really complicated we have
looked at so many tactical variations
involving Queen sacrifices
um some lines where you give up material
and almost check with the other person's
King with this Pawn on H7 is still an
issue for black but maybe Rook H6 maybe
F5 maybe Rook G8 we see so many ideas
for Yan here and for ding they're kind
of not really that many choices so I
don't like this position for ding I
think Jan played the best move Queen G5
stopping all of potential counter play
and he can just sit on this position I
don't think that dingley rent is going
to get much in the way of winning
chances we mentioned an idea with Queen
to B5 at some point that may be an
option but it does allow this Black
Knight into F3 and that's also a problem
not just for the Rooks that are forked
but for the white king in the corner
yeah I think that's a super uh sorry
Italian
I think that's a super important detail
because Queen B5 would allow a lot of
counter would give a lot of counter play
for white attacking they were going to
do six attacking B7 Queen D7 all the all
those things but Knight F3 is probably
absolutely crushing not because you take
a rook but because you're gonna play
Queen to H4 with the threat of Queen H3
and White's King will will just get like
completely destroyed in all these
variations so
if you can't play Queen B5 like what do
you do I'm starting to really be
concerned that Ding is
um like on the verge of just getting
rolled over here
so he needs to find something fast here
I don't know what it is C4 DC4 Queen C3
uh I'm I'm already looking desperate
stuff for for him to try to get some
counter play
abiano
Carver ding's position and he's got all
the reasons to be dingler and in big
trouble in this one if he lets this slip
out if he loses Game 12 it would mean
that yeah she will practically at least
we can say will win the world
championship match ding is not thinking
about striking back right now he is
thinking about survival right now will
he be able to do it we will find out on
the other side of this break
this right here is how I use chestable
and why I've been using it for a long
time I mean if you look up here I've
actually have my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
justinville came around when I got on
chessable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if they're gonna be folders now so
I can categorize my white black and all
tactics in-game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like so
they're like how many adjustable books
you got I'm like all of them how are you
accessible is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time chessable
is the wave this is why I like to use
chelseable it actually helps me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 and bullet and I blame
all of this if like success really it's
just working on chessable just being
honest with you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
the third event in the 2023 Champions
just stop begins in just a few days the
chess kid Club cup play in stage takes
place on Monday May 1st and what a way
to kick off the month the plane
determines who will join Hikaru Nakamura
not a back up to satrobe and our very
own Fabiano caruana in the fight for the
third Champions chest or trophy don't
miss a moment of it use command CCT in
chat for more details you've seen so
much fun at the Champions Chester and
Fabi there is a lot of fun on the board
right now as well so we're gonna jump
straight into the chest and we see quite
a few moves have been played in the
position
yeah right before we went into break I I
briefly mentioned that this was kind of
a desperate try
with two ideas
um
well actually only really one idea the
idea is that you need to get the bishop
to the C2 from C2 to E4
where it's quite an active piece so for
example Rook H6 I don't think the idea
is to take ones before I don't think the
idea is to play D5 because then Rook H6
D5 E5 doesn't really lead anywhere for
white I think but you played Bishop to
E4 after Rook H6 and at least your
Bishop is very active
it's a very logical idea
I see the computer is not at all happy
with it
but
it makes a lot of sense and it came to
mind as as a potential plan for white
it's okay if you pick up the B7 Pawn
Yeah we're starting to get somewhere
with the white pieces in terms of
getting counter play questions can black
go for some sort of direct attack I
don't know it's F3 something like that
easy to imagine also that that white
will get into some serious Danger
and Yan is having a thing here and Fabi
while he takes his time I want to ask
you right after we do Crown the new
world champion we do have the Champions
chest talk coming up and accessible
Masters was an amazing event you had a
fantastic run I know at the end it
didn't work out for you but what a
tournament that was are you looking
forward to the next event of the tour
yeah very much so it's I'll be playing
an event before that and then I'll have
a little bit of time I think to to
prepare for the
uh for the CCT event
and I think so far like the other
players who are playing obviously Hikaru
is qualified no they're back and and
Magnus is qualified right we're getting
the third place
I don't know if they'll all be playing
but I mean it's always super strong no
matter who qualifies like to get to get
to that
um division one or even division two I
mean all these divisions are so so
strong I remember playing division two
and it was like Jan was there and we
were on the same bracket I expected to
play him
but he loses the match to to kramnik and
and so we don't play so like even if you
have you know potentially world champion
in division two it's still you still
might not make it to the to the end of
it like these are such such tough
brackets and we see also these young
players uh like Notre back and uh
um you know prognanta nihal and all
these all these young prodigies are
posing such a challenge even to the best
in the world
ah and right now we see Jana bombshi
posing Big Challenge to dingler and he
goes for the move B5 so Fabi he's
inviting the idea of a check along the
long diagonal echoing the thoughts that
it's not too dangerous because it can be
blocked by that pawn on E6 uh Robert
what do you make of these changes these
structural changes that we've seen in
the last couple of moves I make that
it's a brilliant move and that we see
the glyph appear there it's a double X
lamb and I'm totally with it do you know
how few people would be willing to walk
into a check with D5 that looks very
scary but I believe that B5 it's
unexpected as we see it it does allow a
discover check but it protects the C4
Pawn keeps the extra Pawn there and as
we've been talking about D5 is just a
single check black can push the pawn up
in the center and you also gearing up
your Rook on G6 as well you could take
that Rook but if you do take that Rook
it's not going to end well for white the
Knight on H5 is actually trapped over
there so when a pawn takes back this
Knight gets caught off on the sideline
this is a really really great move from
Yonder palmchi he played it quickly he
played it confidently and it's just one
of those moves that you need to make in
order to become a world champion
important
oh sorry Tanya I'm just gonna say sorry
Bobby just want
just one confidently played by Yan it is
a big problem now for Ding and Fabi
please complete your thought but I want
to also ask you what are the chances of
this game actually being a decisive one
super high I mean we're definitely over
50 that black could win this game uh
just the speed of which he's playing
with the pressure that's on doing the
position obviously is is extremely bad
um for white uh objectively bad at this
point
and I'm just trying to look for chances
and
the only thing that I can immediately
think of because
well white is already down material and
so you could try to regain the material
you could play D5 I think
um because if you take on G6 first it
probably just your knight gets dropped
but after D5 let's say E5
I think you should play E5 Bishop takes
G6
let's say you take with the H1
looks most natural Knight to G3
and the points of fg3 fg3 that night on
H4 is intrap but here I this is where I
think this is important moment I think
the move B4 is super strong and if Queen
C4 Knight to F3
and that was the point that the queen is
distracted so the Knight can escape and
not only Escape when it rook in a
process and if G takes H4 after B4 and
this is the most brutal end that you can
imagine because B takes C3
take the queen and then CB2 and it
doesn't matter that white is temporarily
up in exchange because those two pawns
will cost you at the very least a rook
so why cannot let's say
shoot his way out of this position
there's no the direct tactics just work
out for black
uh the question is can he try to hold on
in the shorter long term what
I'm not sure it's very because I I think
also black
like after let's say A4 some sort of
move to Enderman structure I think black
can just play A6 possibly
I don't think you have to go
or anything super you know uh
anything super like concrete after A4 I
think you could just play A6 you defend
you defend against uh threat of ab5 you
keep your structure intact
black is actually up a pawn and if you
can't take that Rook on G6 then black
will remain upon the question is what
does white have for it not much that I
can see at the moment
Robert this is incredible border
by Yamaha Nebraska I mean they just made
the move
he lines up the queen on the lawn
diagonal to give a check he opens up his
own Bishop on C2 to grab that G6 truck
and Jan says I don't care about either
of these moves you ask the question how
many people in the world can make such a
move I can't think of anyone only Yan
can do Yan things B5 double exclaim
there and this potentially looks like
huge trouble for dingler and he has gone
into a thing almost touching the five
minute Mark do you see a way out here
but dangler and to try to at least
create chances to hold this game
I just think the most impressive part
about all of this is B5 is not an
impossible move to play uh there are
plenty of people you know the top level
who would make this move in the position
but he did in two minutes it's as if he
didn't even need to think he already had
it all figured out he plays this move
understanding this Knight is trapped but
it's not just that the night is trapped
on H5 as Fabiano is just indicating and
highlighting in those variations there
is a lot there where B4 needs to be
flicked in to distract this queen so I
think that this is a brilliant find from
Yonder Palm she especially considering
how quickly he played it that's going
into part of my calculation and I'm
looking at this position ding down to 33
minutes he has 15 moves to make he's
down a pawn his King is more open than
Jan's is
Yanda palmnushi is working his way to a
victory in this game and if he wins this
game a very hard time seeing dingler and
getting back in this match I mean this
would be a great victory for Jana
palmchi and if he wins this he could end
the entire match tomorrow
coupon deficit we have super deficit
comebacks in the world champion
's heart to image task that's even
possible thing will need the biggest of
Miracles to come back in that situation
B5 Yan has done everything flawlessly
and I have to again ask you to Deep dive
into this position Fabi The Rook that
can be picked up on G6 you've been
pointing out these lines that the
drawback in White's position is that the
Knight on H5 doesn't have a retreating
square but if white does get greedy with
the Rook to G6 is that an absolute
disaster in White's position
yeah I think that you cannot take the
Rook on G6 you just have to try to hold
this move by move just not lose on the
spot
probably lose long term but the only way
to even try to defend this position is
just not to lose on the spot I was
thinking of B3 to get some counter play
because you need some space for your
pieces you need some air to breathe but
after B3 I think Rook C8 is super strong
as well
and now the throw is B4 and if B takes
D4 Rook takes C4 you start to collapse
also on the D4 Square uh D4 Pawn as well
and
yeah black is is just crushing I mean
it's it work remains to be done even
here Queen to B3 work remains to be done
it's not you know automatically black
wins but I can take on D4 but there's
still stuff to calculate
and we already see The Rook takes E4
would be like a bit of a night Christy
maybe it's because Queen C3 followed by
Queen to C8 becomes an idea
potentially so
uh so definitely not
like I think Yan will still have to
go through some difficulties to win this
game but if he wins this game I mean
it's not match over but effectively
we've seen as you said we've seen two
point recoveries but the last time that
I can think of that was 1972.
when Fisher lost his first two games
against Sebastian won the match but that
was the first two games that wasn't the
last two games I mean uh having to win
two games on demand against any anyone
is difficult against Dion
who is looking extremely stable last few
days
um yeah pretty much
pretty much an impossibility so thing
really needs to hold this uh and then
you know
at least
it's still a bad match situation but at
least he
A4 okay A6 now we expect to be played
right so hitting that pawn and be Vel B4
is able right now because the C4 Pawn
would
okay so just keeping everything under
control with A6 and once again the
problems are not solved for white yes
you make one move A4 but after A6 ding
we'll have to answer this exact same
questions that are posed right now the
black Rook is coming into the game
threats of B4 after A6 do you see
anything changing with a trade on B5
not really
uh because you can't contest the a file
because there's always you need to work
on E1 to answer Queen D5 with Bishop to
E4 so you don't ever want to play Rook
to A1 like let's say A6 if you ever
after 85 85 play Rook A1 you lose on the
spot taken Queen D5 or queen D5
immediately
as well and uh you well you just lose on
that diagonal so
probably he just played A4 in the
general sense like okay trading puns
I guess can't hurt White
it maybe doesn't help white but it
probably doesn't hurt him either
and he gains a little bit of time on the
clock to think about his next move
while Leon thinks about his move
probably from the comfort of his rest
area
but I suspect A6 is going to be on the
board pretty quickly because it just
isn't so so logical so
simple
just white has nothing that's the
problem for ding right now is you can't
even dream up an attack you know that
the move D5 check is always going to be
met by E5 just block hating in the
center this Knight on H5 is trapped over
here we keep talking about how you can't
afford to take on G6 because the pawn
takes back in the Trap Knight is one so
typically to survive games like this you
need to find some sort of potential plan
some net that your opponent might fall
into your opponent has to see some
ghosts I just don't know where those
ghosts will be seen and this is just a
position where dingley ran down 10
minutes down upon not really with
threats of his own I just fear for him
right now
I I got you Robert I I have a little
idea
yes I'm listening so A6 I take on B5
take back D5 I think E5 is a proper
response now Rook day one now it doesn't
lose on the spot because there's no
Queen D5
where do you put your Rook
cause I'm not sure where it goes but
C8 okay okay C8 and now I want to play
Rook to A6
I'm getting I'm getting something there
right Bishop takes G6 now becomes a
little bit more of a threat
is Bishop to be four crushing it could
be that could be an issue
um or maybe just B4 followed by Knight
to F3 is yeah E4 followed by Knights of
three sounds the game disaster
disastrous
and
not just a disastrous end to the game
that would be a disastrous end for
dingler and in the match now the pregame
odds for Jana promise you with a win in
this match going into game 13 with the
outcome of the current game with a win
and 98 to win a favorite to win the
World Championship with a draw also a
very high percentage at 85 but right now
it is clear that Jana pamushi can smell
blood in this position it is everything
that he could have dreamed off with the
black pieces and dingler and needed to
make a comeback in this game or at least
keep it solid well it looks like that's
going to be a tough task for him and
this is not going to go easy A4 played
on the board thing Lauren is not moving
away ianushi has a short thing and
replies with B4 is this the chance that
Ding has been hoping for we see a slight
Dance by the eval bar thing doesn't
blink picks up the C4 Pawn what's the
idea of this Pawn sacrifice
well I thought like this would naturally
be followed by Knight F3 but then I
thought Knight F3 Queen C6
should be strong
but perhaps there is some tactic for
black here
um
Jan have in mind I'd have three feels
like
a different plan Abby he just goes for
Rook to G8 instead it just feels like he
gave up that C4 Pawn for not much
continues the pressure now Knight F3 is
a big threat you don't have Queen C6
anymore
Robert with this decision by yes
extremely surprised I just don't know
why he did this so quickly and you see
the X usually it marks the spot but here
it marks the a big big mistake here I
mean this was just a rushed decision and
Fabi was talking about the old yon the
yawn that we know I mean this was a Miss
he you know didn't find the move that
would have kept him with the advantage
and I'm pretty sure it was Knight to F3
that Bobby's first instinct here but why
did he Rush this so quickly he's
probably playing into ding's time
trouble a bit but if we just go a half
step back over here Knight F3 yes it
allows Queen C6 but you see after Knight
takes E1 Queen takes eight you have to
calculate that step further after The
Rook blocks the check this bishop is
under attack this queen D5 idea is
definitely in the equation Queen H4
coming and try to Checkmate this King on
the H file this is a big problem for
white and it says to minus almost three
in the position so I just feel like it's
I'm always okay with people miss stuff
nobody's perfect we're all human over
here but to play it that quickly and to
be a Miss I feel like that's always the
worst combination
yeah absolutely and I think the point
that maybe of course he rushed and he
shouldn't have but the final point in
this position which
um like to me didn't come immediately
because I thought white has Queen E4
attacking H7 so black is kind of
obligated to take on C2 not to lose
Queen C2 and it's possible to stop in
this position and think that white is
Consolidated but that final move you
mentioned the idea Queen D5 that's the
crushing move it's it's about
oh okay
I guess not I thought it was as well so
it's maybe just Queen H4 Queen D5 is not
good that's like absolutely shocking
stuff Queen D5 King H2 is that the
reason or well Fabi what's also not good
is ding's decision that he's he's taken
on the in the current live board he went
for the move Queen to C6 the eval bar
bounces straight back to Yan's favor and
is there what is the problem with this
move it does take care of the threat of
Knight F3 but what does it walk into
oh my gosh this is just too complicated
of a position so it's no surprise the
players aren't making mistakes here it's
a really wild Affair and oh it changed
so the more depth it had it went from a
blunder to a mistake so oh and it's
going back so the engine is gaining in
depth it's trying to calculate what is
happening here
it attacks the bishop
and my first instinct is just to move
the bishop somewhere or to defend it and
yawn I thought he was about to grab a
piece that would have been a little bit
too hasty but what is the reply here
I have to say queen C6 is by far the
most natural move
um it's the first one which comes to
mind so
I
it's surprising that it's so bad it's
really it really is surprising of course
it's such a complex position button
maybe there was a bishop takes G6 that
should have been played first but he
plays Bishop B8 does yond apology and oh
my goodness the evaluations went all the
way up and dingley runs favor
oh my goodness what has happened Bishop
to be it a natural defensive move but
now it is Advantage ding what is going
on here you just pick up the Rook on G6
but then there's a
G63 there's this there's this Knight G3
tactic like we mentioned in another
position I think in my work here Bishop
G6 pontics and look ding looks excited
or at least he looks uh
like he's very concentrated is it ages
but I don't know if that works out
because Knight G3 fg3 fg3
like and queen D2 is coming to mind
so what's going on here after Queen D2
oh my gosh let's just let's just pause
we all need to breathe we all need to
breathe for a second oops sorry I keep
refreshing to the beginning we need to
go we need to start from the starting
position but but Bishop BS play we saw
it dink perk up here but Jan continues
to play too quickly like it's okay to
miss things we keep talking because
everyone does it but this is clearly a
critical position Fabi you played a
world championship match and I don't
want to be overly harsh I mean John
Napoli's played a very very excellent
match thus far but when you have a
position that he knew was much better
for him to rush these decisions feels
odd to me maybe he's getting excited
maybe he thinks he's just winning maybe
he wants to put ding in time trouble but
now it's backfired completely and it
definitely Bishop takes G6 we saw is the
first step it's about finding what
happens after hd6 these things are easy
to miss but they're easier to miss when
you don't spend the time to calculate
you know I'm I'm looking at a little
idea after Bishop G6 hd6 I don't know
this could be a terrible blunder I'm
sure the velbar will hate me D5
okay Moment of Truth Moment of Truth
you're brilliant well done Favi if you
take this Knight F6
and if Knight of three I think D takes
E6 yeah this is just winning because the
Knight escapes and obviously black was
counting on trapping that night
and if Knight F3 I think D takes E6 and
then Knight captures one of those Rooks
and then he takes F7 and it kind of
start probably starts to fall apart
um yeah you don't even care about the
Knight on G1 it's all about like Rook
Cafe rookie eight and that stuff or
Queenie as he points it out yikes I
think I think Rook T8 is actually the
way
um so not too loud Bishop D6 and
and then there's a final option after D5
and it's G takes H5 and here I was
hesitating for a second because I
thought the response was G takes but
then Queen F5 is actually threatening
Checkmate so this is not the way to go
because the queen industry is Checkmate
but the way to go is actually D takes C6
and you don't care about h24 because
Rook G4 is is just like attacking
everything and in fact black is falling
into play it's easy to miss this
but black begins to fall apart because F
takes E6 I think
um maybe now gh5 is a better version
but also Rook takes C6 with the threat
of Rook H6 is coming to mind it's of hg4
rookie 6 gh5 also but but this one is
very very uh very scary looking for
black because Rook H6 could just
um end the game
this is a big moment thing needs to
calculate he can find us this is this is
definitely findable for for a player of
his caliber
he's got 25 minutes he needs to burn the
oil right now he needs to burn the clock
a little bit he needs to calculate this
line the tables have completely turned
over the last two moves and we've been
talking about one of Yan's biggest
Trends the ability to play Fast to play
confidently and to make those good moves
on the board but these are exactly the
time when the biggest trends that Yan
has backfires into a weakness in his
game and often brings out the
inconsistency and we saw that with just
two moves B4 giving up that C4 pawn and
the natural looking Rook shift to G8 a
complete turnaround dingler in he needs
to find this option of picking up the
Rook he's definitely looking at that
with the move D5 it reminds me of game
six D5 was the move that got him that
point Robert D5 bringing that mating
attack to the black pieces will ding
find this for the second time in this
match with this killing blow of uh the
pawn advance
I think he absolutely will and I just
want to give a shout out to everybody
watching your enthusiasm is felt I know
you're losing your minds but you're
going to lose your mind even more when
we go through what Yanda Palmer she just
I don't even want to call it overlooking
that's how complicated chess is and
engines they make it look easy because
they just go up and down and tell you
who in fact is winning calculating all
of it is nearly impossible so let's just
go back a step here because ins after
Queen took on C4 Rook AJ was a mistake
Queen C6 apparently also a mistake but
after Knight F3 we were struggling in
this position to figure out okay Rook G8
Queen E4 all this is Forest Checkmate is
threatened you have to take away this
bishop and after Queen takes Queen D5
check looked very good but the bar went
back towards the center after Queen H4
here you have this move
attacking the H3 Pawn oh and the move
has been made it is Queen to B7 I will
get back to this in a second but this
was a very complicated line we'll show
this later because Queen B7 was ding's
Choice he also doesn't find the best
move
yeah these I have to say these guys are
just fried at this point like they've
stopped calculating
um and and you know players they're
they're super strong but they're strong
because they can calculate they're not
strong because they can instantly spot
the best move nobody can so yeah they
turned off their
um their desire to calculate or maybe
just their their tiredness caught up
with them that they don't want to exert
that effort but
they're like it's such a complex
position they're just blitzing and I
have to say I know that there's no
increment and of course time trouble is
uh
you know an enemy of of all of us but
you still have 25 minutes uh Jan has 35
minutes look he's he's getting ready to
move instantly again I mean it's not a
bullet game
this is this is pure nerves that no
longer is this about Chess it's just
pure nerves at this point
every move is a mistake and uh yeah
we're seeing that just because the
players are no longer like ding is ready
to think they're playing like it's
literally a 30 second game not not a
world championship where they both have
you know 25 to 35 minutes
not only caution has been thrown out a
window in this game but also the
accuracy as we see the bar go up and
down the player is keeping the pressure
on the clock but they're just blitzing
out moves in such a critical moment
Bobby you were mentioning about fatigue
and tiredness setting in the inability
to perhaps sit down and calculate at
this point but I have to say this is the
world championship this is the biggest
stage it decides the best player in the
world this is what we expect from the
world number two and the world number
three to figure out but it clearly shows
the aspects of the match the
psychological pressure that is on the
fatigue that sets in the emotional and
the physical toll that it has taken on
these two players now we are currently
on move 30 and we see that Ding has made
the choice Bishop E4 he still has 10
moves to make to meet time controls the
player has two hours to reach 40 moves
and then after that an additional 60
Minute gets added on the clock we often
see that it is a Time scrambled reaching
towards move forward that often decide
the game and it looks like this one is
going to be about that there is no
increment from the start of the game
it's only after move 60 that the players
get a 30 second increment so we are
going to come down to those moments
those critical decision Bishop E4 and
the eval Bar says we are back to level
yeah Bishop E4 was a correct Choice uh
by ding Lee Redden I hope that Jana
stays away for just a second because I
really need to show the variation that
was missed that there was a mistake
because it was so complicated that you
can't fault anyone from missing this so
I am going to go back in time let's
bring up an announced sport really
quickly I will just rush through the
variation but at this point after Queen
takes C4 Knight F3 was correct but the
reason why is crazy and I was informed
of this of course I didn't find this
myself I would never pretend to takes
Queen takes it wasn't Queen D5 it was
Queen H4 threatening mate in one you
play Queen D3 black strikes with F5
please take me your knight is loose on
H5 you can't afford do that F takes G4
is a deadly threat your H Pawn is pinned
and after Queen F3 you defend but after
Pawn takes Rook takes don't take a
knight there's Rook takes G8 check and
the the queen stares at the queen
Through The Rook so this would be a
check and you win the Queen instead you
trade everything Checkmate is thread so
you have to take and then B3 wins at the
end of the line because your knight is
out of play and if you bring your knight
back there's Bishop A3 giving up your
piece and after Pawn takes B2 B1 is
Unstoppable black wins the game okay
John you know he missed this it was a
super easy to find this was like a 10
move variation and this is the only
winning path
yeah this is insane yeah
yeah oh this is a completely crazy
lineup I I don't think that like we can
fault Dion at all for not spotting this
line uh I mean it's super difficult but
I do think that uh not playing A6 was
was kind of very irresponsible because
A6
uh was just a practical decision so he
he's keeping his extra Pawn right and uh
after A6 what is the line that you have
to calculate like
I I actually thought he would play this
quickly
but to play B4 quickly is very
responsible because you're giving up
your C4 pawn and unless you see this
whole Knight F3 to the end and you're
either you're like you know
you know precise calculation to the very
end Super Genius line that you pointed
out
um I think you should play A6 D4 was a
very strange decision
and
now they've I think Jan really needs to
like be careful because it's a position
where as we saw one mistake can change
the evaluation a lot he's still
potentially in danger even though the
position is balanced and obviously ding
is in danger as well
you know F7 is hanging you need to deal
with that pawn which is threatened at
the moment uh it's a big threat if you
lose that point you might just lose the
game it couldn't have been taken the
movie four because of Knight F3
specifically that's why Dane played
Bishop T4
and if you play F5 here I think you lose
the game G takes F5
because Queen takes H5 Rook G8 followed
by Queen takes B8
um the move that black should play is
not instantly evident to me how he deals
with the threat of Queen takes F7
thinkion isn't in danger despite what
developer is saying and he if he keeps
rushing
uh
then yeah he could easily lose I mean I
I don't understand this decision to rush
every move it's a world championship you
have usually one chance in your lifetime
maybe two like Yan has obviously this is
a second world championship match how
can you how can you uh
play every move like it's uh
like it's a title Tuesday game you know
it's it's really these are responsible
decisions to make
some very big misses we've seen by both
these players in the last few moves Yan
missing the most natural option of just
defending it the B5 Pawn keeping
everything under control all your ideas
are still on the board ding would have
had such a tough time to just respond to
that little move that you were pointing
out Fabi and instead he goes for this
line that requires complete Precision it
requires you to if you look at a
variation that is at least 10 moves
ahead with some very unnatural moves and
if you don't make them then you allow
your opponent back into the game we saw
another big Miss by ding when in fact
the valbar would have completely turned
around in his favor the line with D5 so
both players making inaccuracies and
even though the eval Bar says it's level
it's far from an equal position you're
pointing out a direct threat on the
board that Jan that Yan has to deal with
the F7 Pawn is hanging and simple
defensive moves like Rook coming to f8
defending the F7 Pawn do not do the job
because it's not just the F7 Pawn but
also the B4 Pawn that you need to watch
out for now with the black pieces Rook
f8 would run into a move like Queen
takes P4 so definitely not an obvious
way to actually fight against the most
direct threat of picking up the F7 Pawn
yeah yon should really be kicking
himself for getting into such an unclear
situation when he had complete control
over the position
the position is the same except he he
doesn't have a c pawn and White's Queen
is more active he could have had the
same position with an extra C Pawn
White's Queen passively uh placed on on
C3 not particularly threatening black
while here the queen is threatening two
pawns so black uh I guess the B4 Pawn is
the less important one so black should
deal with the threat to the F on but how
do you do that I at this point I prefer
White's position I I don't
um clearly care what the evaluation is
because that's not the reality uh the
reality is that there that Jan has to
find a way to deal with the threat it's
not obvious it's it's really a very
dangerous situation for him here
looks like the tables have really done
the endings favor right now regardless
of what the objective evaluation of the
position is
currently in the resting area he is
definitely thinking about these problems
that look like they're very
self-inflicted with the last few moves
that we saw by Yan with the black pieces
so close to actually wrapping up the
game while we wait for Yan to return to
the board and deal with the immediate
threat on the board that Ding has of
capturing the F7 Pawn we will go into a
break but you don't want to miss the
action on the other side we'll be right
back
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
has not only burnt out the advantage on
the clock but also the advantage on the
board and it was a big one we see that
he has returned on the board he's made a
move he's made his choice and Fabi you
were discussing a fascinating resource
that black has in this position it
wasn't the choice that Jan has gone for
and we see that his move has been
awarded by a question mark That's not
the kind of award you want in this
position
oh it's it's not the kind of a word you
want in any position but it's especially
in this one where the value of each move
is so high because it's so complex and
the valuation can swing so
although moves are coming on the board
quickly the move that we were discussing
in the break was F3 instead of Rook f8
and it kind of felt like intuitively the
right choice
um
with the idea
that after F3 if white so my idea was if
white takes R7 and Knight comes to G2
and starts to create some threats right
black needs control player
and uh some sort of mess and I couldn't
really understand exactly what's going
on but it looked like black kids
counterplay
and if y plays Bishop takes F3
uh then the idea was to take on H5 but
it's also a complete mess and we're
seeing so many moves come on the board
that
that we should probably
complete shift in Dynamics black spaces
are moving back now Robert from being on
the attack on the offense we suddenly
see Yan aparnashi has lost the C4 Pawn
he's lost the B4 Pawn the queen from G5
has moved back to d8 the Rook which was
on an open G line has now shifted to
defending that F7 Pawn this feels like
disaster for Yan
it is a disaster because not only is the
evil are saying white is better unlike
in like the 80 000 different positions
we've looked at where it was confusing
and it said that white is uh better
somehow but it didn't look like it or
black was winning even though it looked
dangerous this version actually looks
good for white your King on H1 feels
much safer there's a bishop on e4 that
Bishop is just defending across this
exposed diagonal this King on h8 if this
queen gets back to the diagonal it could
be in big trouble so that's why I'm
thinking about the move D5 here let me
free up the D4 Square for my queen and
if you don't take this Pawn on D5 I may
take you on E6 I may put a rook behind
my pawn and try to push it up the board
we saw ding with a dangerous d-pawn in
that game eight he didn't win the game
but he should have I don't know this
position is starting to look very very
shaky for yonda palmshi as he's on his
back foot his pieces are sort of
scattered at this point his Knight on H4
is looking good but it's alone in enemy
camp I really like ding's position right
now let's let's continue that line
Robert because that D5 was the move
which came to mind to me as well because
black is has the idea of playing F5 at
some moment and if e takes D5 here Queen
to D4 will regain the pawn and white
will probably enter a very nice end game
uh but after D5 I'm wondering the movie
E5
because black still has that thread of
F5 and this is a concrete position this
is not uh immediately obvious how white
is dealing with the thread of F5 which
which could become very dangerous as
well
so what's what's the follow-up here I'm
not immediately it's not immediately
evident I'm actually thinking of the
idea Queen C3 because I want to play
Knight takes F4 but then F5 comes and
there's Bishop to F3 there it's it's
hard to like yeah probably this doesn't
work out
as Bishop of three feels a bit shaky
right somehow
but yeah but you the Evo bar is like
it's you know inching in One Direction
and then back to a center even it's
confused like this position is that
crazy this King on h8 in the open this
King on H1 not the safest King either
both Knights on the rim they're not
looking particularly dim they actually
look quite aggressive and threatening uh
in Fabia D5 was just a move I didn't
really calculate ideas behind it I'm
being honest with everybody you should
uh come up with plans not just moves but
I'm just looking at this position and I
want to go after this King maybe there's
a better way I don't have to rush what
is Black's next move is it really F5 I
think so I think F5 is coming and the
reason why D5 is a bit double edged is
because after I find that Bishop can go
on the diagonal somewhere and D5 cuts
off a lot of those squares for example
the C6 square is an option
and he plays Queen C3
uh which is more logical without playing
D5 indeed because now after F5 white can
play Bishop to C6 for example
with the idea of D5 at a more opportune
moment and potential exchange sacrifices
in the air for example uh if F5 Bishop
C6 out of black makes a waging move just
to illustrate what y might do next
oops sorry as a mouse slip I mean these
guys are just playing instantly every
move it's amazing what's going on here I
mean they've got more than 20 minutes on
the clock this is a world championship
match the title is at stake and the
players are just blitzing out their
moves in a position where you could be
lost in one move one bad move and the
game is over
yeah it's craziness uh
I mean just to like illustrate something
the Tactical details are white can
actually play the move Knight to F6 here
it is a tactical option it might not be
a good option but it doesn't lose the
Knight because Queen F6 G5 and you pick
up the Rook on on H6 and obviously I
don't know if Knight F6 is the right
move but uh to play instantly in this
position where there's some kind of
sharp stuff like Knight F6 on the cards
and uh and who knows what happens
potentially 906 F3 is actually very
dangerous
but I don't know what that is F3 queen
of three and then the queen can actually
come potentially a D6
um or queen F3 actually Knight to H4 is
super strong so
yeah this actually just wins for black
so the Knight would actually maybe have
to go back to H5 so Knight F6 not
working out the way
uh that why would hope for sure but yeah
yeah I mean you can see how like D5 here
is coming to mind as a very logical move
I think E5 is no longer what black wants
because now it just seems like it kills
your bishop and F5 is no longer a threat
so D5 Bishop to E5 is that the answer
but Bishop T5 Queen to D3
I I don't know looks really nice for
white to me
it was really nice great great
centralization and just to show how easy
it is for Black to drop things Bishop
takes G6 is already a threat with the
bishop loose on E5 over here this is
just a hectic hectic position and both
sides are playing quickly now they have
played 32 moves they need to reach move
40 before gaining time there is no
increment and they don't have that much
time considering how difficult this
position is to calculate but almost
feels like they're putting calculation
on the back burner because they just
want to speed up and at their nerves
there's exhaustion it's just mentally
fatigued considering how tricky this
game has been but I'm looking at this
position and dingly Wren must be
thrilled to be here it looked like he
might lose the match today not because
the match would have officially been
over but being down by two points and
two games to go when Jan has looked
pretty stable good luck to you but now
all of a sudden Jan looks shaky and this
is ding's chance he can't pull a game
eight when he was winning but let Jan
back into it and hold the draw he needs
to take advantage Right Here and Now
Robert you're saying putting calculation
on the back foot I know one person who's
not going to be happy about that our
friend James Canty because it has to be
calculation over everything they needed
to have that chat with James about this
position and Jan would have been a happy
man but instead now he's just playing so
fast he's blitzing it out uh Fabi do you
think this is Yan's way of trying to get
into those time scrambles of putting a
ding into a pressure situation he seemed
in collapse in that is that the whole
big hope for Yan right now
oh well I'm reminded of some
um advice by one of my former coaches
because I used to as a kid play
absolutely instantly
um in any position very often to my
detriment and he said that you know when
you have a bad position
uh it makes sense to try to press your
opponent on time
like let's say your opponent's in time
travel when you have a bad position it
makes sense because you're you're gonna
you're objectively in bad shape anyway
you might be losing and probably your
best chance is to Bluff your way out of
it when you have a good position you
don't need to Bluff you just have a good
position all you need to do is find the
Right Moves to convert your advantage
and so there was no point earlier in the
game Jan's decision to put pressure on
ding with natural moves with all these
intuitive moves that we really liked
like Queen G5 uh Knight t7 Knight H4 all
this stuff Rooks G8 uh his play was
absolutely brilliant we we can't uh
fault him for a single decision because
it was it was like world-class uh or
even better than world class I would say
like you know the the best of the best
um for most of this game once he reached
a winning position he didn't slow down
that was the moment where he had the
objective Factor he didn't need to try
to Bluff ding or put pressure on him
because the pressure was in the position
so again I I just want to like reiterate
that these aren't chess mistakes
this is not about Chess anymore this is
just about psychology and
um keeping it under keeping it together
under really strong pressure of a world
championship match
this is that's purely what this is uh
obviously
both of these guys know the complexity
is is super intense in this position so
just by pure logic not even thinking
about the position in complex positions
you need to take time to figure out the
right path for anyone nobody will
intuitively
um unless you're obviously an engine and
we even see the engine sometimes you
know uh adjust its evaluation based on
the amount of time it takes to think so
if even an engine is confused here
uh how can a human not be right these
guys really should have been taking more
time especially on because ding I
understand
bad position you want to kind of Blitz
it out standard uh sort of practice for
defense to try to Blitz your opponent
but for yawn really he dropped the ball
by not taking more time
yeah Robin I was just about to say the
same thing ding a couple of minutes back
looked like he was about to make a move
really right now you look
he looked under pressure feeling the
Heat of the Moment and that's what he
has to make sure doesn't happen he still
has some critical choices to make he
still has some big decisions to make he
reaches out and makes the move Queen to
Bishop to G2 retreating with the bishop
that kind of fights against the ideas of
F3 defends that H3 Pawn I see our eval
bar still pretty much remains around the
around the even point but ding there
Robert definitely giving signs that he's
not feeling confident currently in this
position
yeah it's a different kind of pressure
because earlier in this game he was in
big PR under big pressure he was
probably almost lost over the board now
he's under pressure because he knows
he's escaped and he's like I'm right
back in this but I still need to win I
still need to reach move 40. I only have
13 minutes left I don't mind Bishop G2 I
don't care if the engine says it's a
mistake because Black's best move might
be something that's hard to find and
this position is really one where I
don't want to play it ever I'm looking
at this I'm scared because with both
sides I would make 20 000 mistakes and
you don't even get 20 000 moves so I'm
just looking at this and I just don't
blame either player but I do agree with
Favi earlier Jan should have slowed down
that was the big turning point in this
game if Janet slowed down he would not
have given all this counter Play Because
ding's position is just more free it's
more flowing it's just more fun for him
to play so by the way let's talk about
bad pieces there's a rook on H6 earlier
that was an aggressive piece now it
can't move it's stuck over here staring
into a knight that's well defended by a
pawn the bishop back to G2 took F5 out
of the equation you want to play F5 in
many of these positions you're just
gonna drop this Pawn on E6 that is not
acceptable so what does black do here D5
is still a threat in most of these
positions with the King over here on h8
this is really tough positioning and I
think that Ding did not want to allow
the bishop to E5 and that's why he first
brought his Bishop back so D5 can no
longer be met by Bishop B5
is your question what does black one
want to do the attack he was on the
offense went back to defend the Rook on
the defense and now back to the
offensive Place Queen H4 so still
hitting ideas of the H3 Pawn but more
importantly the F2 Pawn super tender
there and ding takes an immediate
decision he just simply Gods it passes
the ball back to Yan saying I've got the
ideas of D5 all the points that you were
making earlier Robert and it's again
practical problems but this time for Yan
to solve
I'm really tempted by white to play D5 I
understand why he's keeping in reserve
and it makes sense to but
physically speaking if white can force
D5 E5 which it seems to do that black
kind of has to play E5 after D5 this is
a a great thing for white no I mean like
endgame suddenly are probably winning
for what as you mentioned Robert that
Rook on H6 is
really in bad shape I mean it's not
trapped it does perform some useful
functions in terms of if the Knight on
H5 moves and obviously the root can
become an attacking piece but if we
imagined that the Queens came off the
board and white had Bishops F3 like The
Rook also can get trapped potentially
with G5 so it it's very often in danger
of getting uh just lost on H6
and and what does black do here after
rookie two it's not obvious the next
move
well I think this is why he didn't play
D5 quick a little analysis here it's not
going to be long but for everybody
wondering why wouldn't you just give a
check sometimes it's better to store the
threat is better than the execution
after D5 E5 black can successfully play
F5 in the near future and that's scary
for the white king in the corner but in
the game after Rook to E2 a very quiet
move if you play F5 Now The Rook which
was defending says thank you very much
for the pawn and D5 will result in a
mating attack against the king so I
actually really like rookie too it takes
away Black's main offensive threat and
says you need to find a move because
you're not going to sacrifice in
exchange I can just take right back and
my king is perfectly safe thanks to the
bishop and let's not forget that white
is up a Pawn on the queen side if black
just shuffles back and forth at some
point white can throw those pawns up the
board and try to get a pass Pawn so I'm
really worried for Jana Palm I know
he's up seven minutes but I really feel
like his position is far more difficult
to play I'm struggling to see move here
you just brought your queen to H4 that's
a good square but you're not threatening
anything this Rook on f8 does it have to
stay here for some reason can it move to
a square like d8 I don't even know if
that does anything
yeah if if I were young here I would be
in a state of panic this is a position
where you need to immediately generate
ideas or you could easily lose the game
because
yeah it's only the dynamic factors that
can maybe save you here you're down
material so that's the first thing
that white is up a pawn black is the one
who needs to prove compensation and the
other thing is that the D5 idea at any
moment could result in in your king
getting mated so you have to both create
counter play and keep an eye on your
king which is very weak
and I don't see how to do it F5 is like
the most obvious move I'm actually
thinking about some kind of crazy A5
here
um just because I
plays F5 it's losing the spot and oh
my gosh Rook takes C6
F takes G4 let's D5 Bishop B5 rookie
five I don't see the idea there for
black
it's just checking
um
I'm shocked I'm confused is this Jan on
tilt
rookie six I don't understand it F3 is
his idea
so F3 so we need to analyze this we have
to be a city otherwise you resign no F3
D5 is F3 so your point just to show that
white could get checkmated if your
Bishop were to take that would be silly
because you get checked into one okay so
F3 if Queen takes F3 you're trying to
take on G4 and expose and attack against
this Queen it has an easy reputation D5
Bishop to E5
Rook takes E5 F takes G2 and I think
just King maybe King G2 also wins but
King H2 is a very simple solution I
think
and yeah the king is safe
F takes G4 leads to mate after Rook to
F5
among all the other moves as well or
Rook G5 whatever you want uh Knight
takes C5 Queen E5 will yeah why does and
he played it he played rookie six
this is complete craziness I I can't
imagine this
disaster
I've lost out on an Advantage given the
chance to dink to strike back and did
you see that Ding actually looked at Yan
he looked at Yan there with this puzzled
expression Jan has blown this away Rook
E6 on the board no way for Yan to come
back if F3 doesn't work that is the
third Pawn that Jan has just given to
ding for free what is this this is
supposed to be a world championship
match and this is why dingley Rand
played Rook E2 that was a really subtle
idea it was just defending of course a
pawn that was under attack but he made
it so Jan could not successfully play
this active move F5 so I think that
dingley Wren deserves a ton of credit
yes Jana palmchi is absolutely
collapsing at this stage of the world
championship game 12. but ding has
created some problems for Yan Yan's
created problems for himself as well and
now the game is just over there's no way
to save this King
did you see Yonder it looked like he was
so angry at himself what he allowed he
couldn't even look at the board he was
just talking to himself just in complete
disbelief of how he's just left the
title the world championship Crown just
slip out of his hand in this game 12.
Yana promise you feeling the heat
dangler and in driving seat is not just
about losing this game and things
striking back but if that was to happen
at this moment yeah knowing what he
messed up
Fabi the momentum of the match will
completely shift in ding's favor with
this comeback
yeah it's difficult to um
because I on the one hand
uh I really feel for Eon in this in this
moment uh it's clear the pressure
got to him
and I I think that it got to him because
he probably realized that he was on the
verge of winning a game which would
probably win him
probably win in the match we can't say
with certainty but
with the great likelihood two-point
margin would be too much to handle and
at that very moment when we were already
calling
where he like you know maybe on is going
to become world champion very soon uh
he every move like we can basically
criticize pretty much every move he made
um it became like a Bully game just
instant moves and
uh within the span of 10 moves at least
like seven serious mistakes uh you know
just just very like the quality just
went
uh basically to to zero
so
and with 40 minutes on the clock
not like when when ding collapsed in
game seven
uh it was shocking but it was still
very much associated with time trouble
panic this was unprovoked unprovoked
mistakes just pressure of the match
dictated uh what happened at the end of
this game
and now he's he's of course
as soon as Rook 66 happened he
understood
what he had done to his position but it
was already headed that direction like
he had gone from completely winning to
um
like just compare the position before B4
and and before F5 it's the same position
without his B and C pawns exactly the
same he's just missing his B and C forms
besides that the position is identical
we've maneuvered a lot but uh but the
BNC points somehow magically disappeared
from the board
and obviously something went pretty
wrong for that to happen so yeah just uh
he's he's definitely kicking himself who
knows what
uh what this means this is a hardware
thing to watch to watch Yan right now is
is Spain because he can feel it he's
talking to himself he's not being able
to look at the Port this was a big a big
missed opportunity
from a completely winning position and
it was flawlessly played by Jan up to
that point ding Hanging On by a thread
and then just a bad move one after the
other has seen a complete collapse and
at this world championship stage I'm not
used to seeing something like this we
usually see play which is you know we've
seen the highest accuracy by these two
players in the previous games and Robert
this has been shocking and currently
just heartbreaking to watch Yan on the
board
it's been shocking but you know if you
think of the match overall is this the
first time where dingley Ren received
some luck because when I think of game
seven where he got in time trouble he
was the one who was out playing yonda
palmchi in game eight he had a winning
position now Jan put up some very
stubborn defense but dingley Ren
outplayed him had a winning position and
didn't win the game so I feel like this
actually is a moment where dingly Ren is
experiencing some Fortune because his
position was terrible and it happens to
be very late in the match and we'll get
some recency bias but if I think for a
second and look the match as a whole
dingley Ren I didn't think he deserved
to be trailing based on the way he
played so I feel like for dingley Ren
this is a huge moment he is bouncing
back he is about to level this match up
and I wouldn't say he is undeserving of
being six to six after game 12. so he
could have lost the match in this game
and that is fortunate for him but if I
just take a step back if I look at the
match as a whole dingley Wren has not
been a worse player I think this they've
been very level and so six score feels
about right
yeah I don't think that we can talk
about luck because this has been up and
down and
uh for sure thing is not lucky to be in
this position or I mean maybe
considering what what the position was
30 minutes ago we can say that but as a
whole yeah uh
obviously he's counting his lucky stars
because things could have been a lot
worse but
you know both these guys made mistakes
throughout this match they
they had their chances they they missed
their chances as well uh I can think of
like one moment where Jan will
definitely regret uh earlier in the
match which was when he sacrificed when
he decided to take the exchange right
and he allowed this monster
uh monster Knight on F5 and
um in the English game reverse Sicilian
game earlier in the match I think it was
probably game four
so so there's definitely some moments
they can both regret so far for ding of
course game seven and game eight that
was a nightmare stretch for him because
he could have been he could have been
two out of two instead of half out of
two from those two games
oh my God what we're witnessing right
now is just it's on surpassed it's
something that we haven't seen happen
before this to me looks like ding has
used up one of his nine lives today
surviving this one and simply because
Jan played such a great game from the
start he took his chances he went for
shot Castle he went into that deep dark
Forest we keep coming back to of
complications he did not shy away from
it some Brave Fearless decisions I'm
still thinking Robert how do you explain
the last few moves by Yan being so close
to it but move by move just undoing
everything that you've created being so
close to becoming world champion yes not
for certainty but for our practical
purposes it was clear and Yan right now
is fighting the demons in his head
because he's also thinking about what
he's missed out on his game not just the
fact that he's completely lost but the
fact that he perhaps lost the world
championship title with this game
it's an impossible question to answer
and the reason why is it's an impossible
experience a POS impossible situation to
replicate without being in the world
championship stage now we have somebody
who played a world championship match
against Magnus Carlson that's Fabiano
with us uh but I think one of the big
differences is that yadavi had the lead
and he was about to make it a two-point
lead and so Fabi I mean you can maybe
comment on this I don't know it's kind
of speculation to some extent but nerves
had to be a huge factor and the
exhaustion after playing now a 12th game
of chess you know that these players
have been giving it their all they
really must be just out of gas
yeah exhaustion is definitely playing a
huge part in this and uh I think also
the weight of the moment
because I'm sure yawn realized like some
part of him understood that he's very
very close in this game to winning the
game and to making that huge step
forward to becoming world champion and
the weight of that also can weigh on you
it can get in your head a bit the
excitement of potentially winning also a
brilliant game I'm sure he felt like he
was playing a brilliant game winning a
brilliant game with the black pieces
um the the whole Narrative of it is in
your head like I'm I'm going to win a
world championship match with uh one of
the best games I've uh I've ever played
you know just slowly out playing a
player as good as ding from an equal
position like just from the opening
equal maybe even slightly worse from
black so all of this was in his head I'm
sure that
um is contributed in great part to why
uh yeah and I I can feel I think all of
us everyone in the chat can also feel
the pain of uh losing losing a chess
game we've all been there
so this is brutal this is brutal
chess but also just how cruel a game it
is and we can see that on yand right now
and
Robert he's fighting a bad position but
right now he's fighting his mind and how
difficult is it for him to even try to
create chances here if you just look at
it from a practical purpose is there a
way now for Yan to try to hold it or is
it completely a lost cause he might
resign now this game is over and he
knows it I mean I don't know if this was
just he forgot the E6 Pawn was hanging
directly or if he was relying on
something but there isn't anything here
and I feel free on him you look at him
right he is absolutely devastated
because he had a world championship
title which is right there in his hands
and it just fell out of his grasp and
now all of a sudden he's dead lost in
this game it's about to be six to six he
does get the white pieces tomorrow but
his mentality has to shift he needs to
play for a win he's to play something
not you know he doesn't have to go all
in of course but he needs to start
playing ambitiously whereas if he had
drawn today or if he had won today he
would have just played a solid game so I
think he's just going back in this game
thinking what was I doing how could I
not get the most out of this position
how could I not win but he is going to
resign he is going to lose this game and
he will need to clear his head for
tomorrow
he's in agony right now
yeah there's no there's no way to fight
uh D5 is coming no matter what movie
make
just D5 next it's uh
there's nothing left no hope left
yeah this is
I think his task now will be
to uh recover mentally from this one
this is this is going to be a tough one
to recover from
and just to push back on that that's
exactly what it was right Fabi it's not
just about ding making his comeback in
this match but yeah and being so close
to closing the match having a winning
position with the black piece is Yan did
it once in game two he took the first
win with black and he almost did it at
the most critical point almost being the
key word here but it just looked like he
went suddenly on a self-destruct mode
that he start playing on them on ding's
clock was he so confident that he was
blitzing at moves and overlooking things
questions which not only we are asking
as commentators let's chat with Yan also
has to answer for himself what happened
and of course if ding takes this one Yan
will not even have time there's no rest
day to recover before the next game and
look at Ian he's unable to look at the
position right now
yeah
um I I think that
you know I've had these moments as well
where you where you do something and
then afterwards you're like how could I
have possibly done this and then it's
just going through your head like all
the moments in the game where he uh
there was some good moves some good
chance or just thinking back on that
position
after a four like one I just play A6 and
let my opponent
stir in his thoughts of how to create
some Contra play rather than
uh I think we really need to maybe go
back to that moment in the analysis
because
like this this is a
this is this is just a ruin of a
position
um yeah
and we might we might see Robert as you
mentioned a resignation here because
it's difficult to even come up with a
move for black
again he's not
he's not lines it's just hard to come up
with a response currently with the black
pieces Rook takes E6 picking up that
third Pawn by dingler in has just left
Yan with a completely lost busted
position here which means that Ding is
right now staring at a comeback for the
third time Jan continues to be in
disbelief he is running down on the
clock as well we haven't seen that
happen something that Jan probably did
not expect it even in the worst
nightmare from the position that he was
coming from he's down to five and a half
minutes on the clock but it's not about
the clock the position is completely
lost for black the threat of D5 on the
board nothing saving Black's King Jan
was the one who was on the attack
throughout putting that pressure on
dings King and ding also realizes it he
knows he's keeping his calm he's keeping
his composure but this is a big moment
for ding as he's staring at his third
comeback at a very critical moment where
he will equalize the match going into
the final two games of the world
championship and you can see it on you
know and Ding and he just is more
determined than ever he had his back
against a proverbial wall he was in
trouble he went for it it was backfiring
everything was going wrong for him but
he fought very hard to get back into
this game and Jan you know he was his
Own Worst Enemy that quick decision
making something we've said about Jan in
the past we thought that you know he's
changed a lot winning the candidates
twice playing a world championship match
back in 2021 against Magnus Carlsen but
sometimes you know our worst habits come
back at the worst possible moment and
Jan is going to be very upset with
himself for some of his quick decisions
allowing dingly Wren some much needed
counter play and right now Jan has no
counter play of his own he is down
material he is down on time his King is
about to be knocked down because he
might just resign here this is 1-0 and
that means we'll have a 6-6 match
yeah I think it's
uh I mean I I do kind of see a move to
resign it suddenly came to me uh it's
the move Knight to E5
is it if Rook h69 G4
there's there's a d595 there's actually
a thread of Knight takes up too it's a
pretty strong threat it probably doesn't
work out for black anyway but
uh
you know I think at this point Jan is
just incapable of making a move right
now he's just in complete shock
no I'm just trying to like find uh some
move not to resign the game on the spot
at least to create the chance for a
mistake for your opponent but after
Knight takes you 95 I think Rook takes
E5 is like
just very very clinical and easily
crushing black
so uh even even 95
uh
and that was that would be a great I
think bullet try I mean
like Hikaru would play that and and
probably win
uh entitled Tuesday if
if he were doing that but yeah here here
it's um
it's not too difficult to refute it's
painful to watch this honestly I'm
looking at Yan I'm seeing that just pure
Devastation that anger and it gets to
you and as a fan of Chess in addition to
commentating you know you always want to
see great games all these great Fighters
but it's painful as somebody who's
played a lot of Chess to lose a game
like this I mean I've never been on this
stage of course probably you have been
but I think we can all can understand
what Jan is going there's a very human
moment and I feel for him even though if
you're a dingly red fan you're thrilled
I think even then you're still upset for
Jan just because of you know how he's
feeling right now
yeah absolutely it's uh
it's obviously very very painful to lose
in general and especially on the biggest
stage
and yeah we saw exchanges like Queen
takes H5 likely maybe F3 I don't know
uh
F3 D5
seems Seems to
seem D5 Bishop P5 rookie five there's a
little bit to calculate F takes G2 King
takes G2
uh uh Knight F4 the king runs
instead he takes I think D5 here
followed by D6 is very clinical King age
King G8 D6 and
that's the black king
is getting hunted and wide is up a lot
of material so D6 quickly played and
resigned handshakes and that is it E6 on
the board it is game over the England
comes back in the match after a very
twist a lot of twists and turns in this
one yeah resigns in that position wow
we've got a match on our hands
I'm impressed that that Jan is
willing to discuss the game after
because
obviously it's such a
such a bad moment for him in this match
and he must be completely
uh
really disgusted with how it all ended
today
that was your big heartbreak moment for
Yan who was completely winning and he
was better for the most part of the game
with dingler and hanging by a thread
used his opportunity we saw a Collapse
by Yan move after move and with that
going into game 13 it means we've got
the level score and of course now for
Jan as well dealing with this
psychologically not just the result but
the way the game went how close he was
to actually wrapping up the match this
is going to be a tough night for
janapamnushi
yeah I don't know how he's going to be
able to sleep and I definitely don't
know how he's going to be able to answer
questions in that press conference but
ding Lee Ren is back in it so as much
sadness as Jan Napalm says there's a bit
of schadenfrotta where it's it's going
to be a thrilling experience for dingley
Ren because he was about to be
eliminated now he is leveled up he is
tied this match and I mean this was a
very interesting game even though it was
imperfect
and it started with a slow opening but
we saw so many critical moments in this
one Fabi take us through the action and
the big moments that we had where Yan
could have actually wrapped up the game
it feels like a million years ago when
we were discussing the intricacies of
this unusual Bishop D7 move
but so much happened in this game that
the opening
uh feels like a distant memory so Bishop
to D3 happened here Knight to C6 short
Castle Bishop to G4 we were discussing
the best way to play for both sides but
um perhaps sting did not find the best
way in this position Rook to E1
he played E6 Knight to F1 Bishop D6 and
here very interesting move by ding
Bishop to G5 this was actually kind of
an important branchy moment because
although Bishop G5 or 9g3 are both fine
moves this is the one that started the
whole craziness that that persisted for
the rest of the game short Castle
excellent move by Yan and uh he
continued to play excellently Bishop
takes F6 gf6 Knight to G3
F5 we were kind of expecting this might
happen H3
Bishop F3 Queen F3 and here to avoid the
potential Knight takes upside Knight
takes F5 sacrifice
Beyond played Knight to E7 very
interesting move
inviting Knight H5 as played by Ding
King to h8 G4 obviously both sides are
um
staking out their you know their way to
attack on the king side now G4 played
Rook to G8 played to stop gf5 and after
King to H1 Knight to G6
excellent move here we started to see
the difficulties for ding as Knight to
H4 was coming on the board and he
started to maybe drift a little bit
I just want to show this one more time
because it was such a brilliant tactical
variation where this looks winning for
white but in fact black gets there first
throwing a check throwing another check
and then the moves that were really
difficult is Bishop E7 stopping the
White Queen from checking here and
delivering mate and after F6 it looks
like mate or wind of a piece is
unavoidable but there is some brilliant
stuff Knight F5 cutting off circulation
between Queen and Bishop on H7 and if
you take this Knight which is attacking
the queen then you get checkmated
because Queen C4 takes away the king's
Escape Route and after rookie to Rook H1
is made so this was a gorgeous tactical
uh possibilities didn't happen but still
Worth showing
yeah this was one of the lines we were
fascinated with and instead of doing
Play Bishop C2 although we were
speculating that maybe Rook to G1 was a
better move
and after Bishop C2 Yan started to play
absolutely brilliant chess Knight to H4
the queen moved
now Rook to G6 came
and now he played
Rook to G1 yeah that's right um
and F4 Queen D3 and now Queen to E7
excellent idea of putting the queen on
G5 I mean all these moves were perfect
it's like brilliant he's just block
hitting on the dark squares and slowly
slowly going to break through on the
king side with an attack rookie won
Queen G5
and in desperation being played C4 upon
sacrifice which probably doesn't work
out but he was already the pressure was
mounting so maybe a practical decision
this wasn't a bad one DC4 Queen C3 he's
Ein uh some D5 ideas but yeah an
excellent move B5 not worried about
Bishop takes G6
because after 86 tonight on H5 would be
trapped
now dink played the move A4
very logical
and I think this was a crucial moment in
the game ifiana played A6
we will come back to that we've got the
players in the press conference let's
head over to Astana
foreign
welcome at the press conference of the
round 12. today the game was won by Ding
leren and the current score is tight six
to six uh my first question goes to ding
um around move 28 to 30.
moves both sides you started to Blitz
out the moves and there were a lot of
inaccuracies and there is a quote from
Fabiano caruana who said there is no
longer about Chess it's pure nerves
every move is a mistake now would you
agree to this statement
well I I agree with the first part of
his
the words not about Chess since yeah I
know the quality will be very low but
actually I'm not so nervous at the point
yeah I thought
at one point I feel it's totally silence
silence in the playing Hall and
I feel
I didn't feel anybody watching the games
it seems the playing field
well it seems to be the very important
game but I didn't feel it at all
I I have to
told myself that it's quite important I
have to focus on I didn't feel any kinds
of you know emotional at that point
yeah but yeah the game itself is quite
bad I think my mistake came earlier is
Bishop C2 I should have played Rook G1 I
guess Bishop H2 and then Rook F1
maybe that's the improvement over the
game
right yeah
thank you and Jan would you agree to
this statement of Fabiano caruana that
it's no longer about Chess but it's
about the nerves now oh no I guess it's
still about Chess and they are not
not the best thing to do like to to lose
him supposedly winning position
um I guess uh after C4 like something
like Rook C8 broken C5 will be like very
very clean
and then basically why it has no counter
play so it's pretty much
um in my opinion pretty much over since
cd5 doesn't work
uh yeah but uh I somehow decided to go
for some forcing lines and met the
consequences
so yeah I think it's pretty much chess
but yeah at some point of course it was
um a big big mess
uh but
um yeah once I found out that okay this
I mean I'm not sure after Bishop E4 says
Strangely I didn't see like any ideas
for me anymore yeah so perhaps okay what
I did was
reasonable but uh yeah clearly it was an
important one and an important moment
so yeah but
happens
thank you um I think at what moment have
you realized that the tables turned on
your side
well I didn't understand his choice
before and then didn't Follow by Knight
F3
just gave me a very
very uh
easier play and my queen has developed
to a very good Square so but after
Bishop E4 I realized I was maybe already
better at that point
right have you considered actually to
capture The Rook on G6 be
instead of playing
playing if he takes
so you considered but you disliked that
that much yeah because it's considered a
little bit yeah but I think when I saw
Queen B7 Then followed by Bishop E4 I
thought it's quite good for what
okay thank you
um
one last question from me and then we'll
go to press just the questions yeah and
you played very sharp moves and got a
great advantage on the king side
when the thing started to go wrong
exactly for you
uh as I mentioned already yeah probably
the whole concept like we've capturing
on C4 was unnecessary so I could see it
and keeping the center closed
uh I guess it was pretty much it but uh
yeah what to do okay fair enough uh do
we have questions now in the Press
please launcher leoncho Garcia from El
Pais today I have the same question for
both
millions of testamenters all over the
world were following the game with the
help of very uh powerful computers which
were saying that black was winning for a
lot of time and then at certain moments
that white was winning but both of you
are human beings so I think it will be
very interesting if you can explain as
best as possible how were your feelings
during the critical part of the game for
instance Ian did you feel completely
winning linen did you feel totally lost
let's start uh firstly on with you oh
yeah indeed it looks like winning
I think uh the whole like attack on the
king side doesn't work here but yeah it
looked promising yeah but still you like
even if you are winning you still got to
be precise till the end and clearly I
wasn't precise tonight today
what about your thing well I thought I
was better out of the opening but after
he played a series of very good moves
the table had turned around and I
realized after he played H4 ff4
and then Queen Seven quite strong also
Queen G5 the best after that I thought I
was nearly lost so I have to complicate
The Waters by princy for Queen's history
thanks a lot
thank you next question please
um
the question is to you my name is from
match TV channel
were you glad with your moves Bishop G7
and then Bishop G4
so did you play by the book could you
explain yeah I guess
please answer in Russian and we'll
translate yes
foreign
it was part of my preparation and by the
results of the debut I was happy with
right next question and I have a
question uh to Dean uh Dean were you
surprised with Bishop D7 Bishop G4 all
this maneuver have you seen it before
uh I'm quite happy to see Bishop D7 come
over the board one hour sit in the
restroom because maybe he's worried
about Bishop B5 if we play B9 C6 but
actually 9 C6 was the best move
according to my analyze so it means he's
a temple down comparing to the normal
position
next question
uh hello um
I have a question for ding on the Move
12 or when your token F6 you spend half
an hour thinking on that move
coincidentally it's also move 12 in the
second game where you did not expect the
capture on F6 is there any psychology
behind thinking for so long on that move
or is it completely irrelevant well I
was choosing between Bishop F6 and
Knight G3 or 93 ISO Knight H5 H3 Bishop
Tech now Queen takes Knight takes pound
tax visual text and then maybe rookies
three but here make bishop D6 also works
so I have to choose between these two
simply equal
variations it's very hard to decide
which one is better in the end I think
maybe
to take the Knight first
so you were just thinking about the
lines there's nothing psychological but
after a take he takes a pump it reminds
me a little bit remind you of the games
yeah thank you
thank you do we have more questions in
price
I would ask myself one question to
um Jan if you were surprised by the
opening choice of doing when he played
movie three call system as it's it has a
reputation that it's not so ambitious
move oh no I wasn't surprised you're
prepared for it
all right uh next question
to ding
when you went A4 if nepo had gone for A6
what was your idea is 8.6 maybe take 35
E5 and Rook A1 did you see that on the
board what order was that your
preparation
no no
it's already in the middle game I would
totally lost
okay thank you
thank you I think now it's time of the
Twitter segment please just bring the
questions Jesse February here
my first question is beyond
what were you discussing at the board
right after the game
ah I guess
instead of a fight which was not so
fortunate I also calculated F3 Queen F3
F5 but
um yeah we discussed some some lines
afterwards
and for both of you if they if the aims
were to go to the
which time control would you feel more
comfortable playing what do you think
the odds would be
I think we will go with with you first
well I'm quite happy to play 25 plus 10
seconds
with four rounds yeah it's
it's a
yeah we because I have played many many
tournaments like this time come true
right yeah
um
I mean there are like two classical
games so that's that's not the time to
to think about it
okay thank you
my last question is for Jan
uh this is not the first time you've
managed to open up the G file and used
it to attack
did you feel you were better at any
point after G takes ah
yeah good question I think after
uh afternoon just six uh okay after all
this G4 plan black is massively better
might be not winning but surely black
has an upper hand
and I guess the fun part that's like
I guess instead of five okay yeah
freaking free of five Queen E3 like
whatever like 94 takes and after X G4 uh
should also be quite so right for black
but yeah
uh happens as I said
thank you
uh do we have more questions this can be
the last chance for the press to ask the
question
otherwise I would like to conclude
today's press conference tomorrow the
round 13 will start
at 3 P.M local time so thank you very
much
[Applause]
England Wins Game 12 with that he is
back in the match he only decisive game
of the second half comes at a very
critical moment and what a game this was
with that win we've got a level score
with six six Jana bombushi has so much
to deal with after what has just
happened we saw them at the press
conference Yan seemed composed given
what he had just well what we had just
experienced what we have just witnessed
he was frustrated on the board
disappointed angry with what had just
happened and after five draws we get one
decisive game a big big win sorry four
draws we get a big win by dingler in but
yeah
Fabi in your experience the match is
level far from over what does he need to
do to get back from what happened today
well I could say my match was uh the
same after 12 games the same score but
we had gotten there in slightly
different ways
um yeah and there were some adventures
in my match but nothing like this I I
can't think of a world championship
match this adventurous until maybe going
back to 2006 to Paulo of uh to Paul of
kramnik that's I mean that was this
level of crazy but this is pretty wild
stuff and at the moment ding definitely
has the upper hand in terms of the
psychology
uh I'm sure that he's absolutely
thrilled I mean he could have basically
been out of it and now it's pure 50 50.
if we look at the numbers if we think
about
uh what happened to get there today the
chance that Jan had and how he'll
probably be
um ruminating over that for
for the rest of the night
we can speculate about how that will
affect him
we have seen the players have shown a
tendency to come back from tough losses
and they've struck back very often in
the very next game will that happen
tomorrow it's impossible to say but
definitely will be exciting to watch
yeah I mean those draws were just the
Calm before the storm because today's
game was topsy-turvy Yana palmchi he had
the world championship match he was so
close to pretty much winning it today
and yet he slipped dingly Ren much more
confident now than he could have been uh
during this game and he's got great
chances he does have the black pieces
tomorrow as Fabi said we saw earlier in
the match they were trading decisive
victories uh first ding would won game
four then yawning game five ding in game
six young and game seven so Jan has
proven that he can win the day after a
loss he is able to bounce back but I
think this is heartbreaking I don't just
think he'll be ruminating on it tonight
I think he's gonna be thinking about
this game for the rest of his life and
whether or not he does eventually become
the world champion so it was a really
hectic game the fans were treated to
chaos but I think the players I mean
they're gonna need to find a way to
settle down because tomorrow is a whole
new day
and a really big one and unfortunately
for Yan No Rest days no time to recover
from what he went through today we could
see the agony in him so close to
actually just closing down the match
with a move after move collapse and
dingler and took that point now ding
will be playing with the black pieces
the good news for Jan is that he starts
tomorrow with white what are you
expecting Fabi with the action that
we've seen today will Yan try to create
his chances and try to take risks with
white or will he just want to stop the
bleeding
I think we will see first move E4 I
think John should stick to his guns and
probably will stick to his guns at the
moment there's it doesn't make sense to
take huge risks because at the moment
after such a traumatic game of course if
you take chance if you get chances take
them but don't try to push too hard
don't try to force the matter because uh
two draws and going to a playoff at this
point I think yam should be happy with
that then we wouldn't have said that
yesterday but he doesn't want to to
spiral out of control to go and tilt as
as they say I think that uh he should
you know still play ambitiously tomorrow
but not in a way where he ever risks
losing control his his number one uh
priority should be quality good chess
and keeping control the situation
much time to recover but yeah zingler
into incredible Fighters they will be
back tomorrow for a very crucial game 13
we still have two classical Games The
Players gave their thoughts on the tie
breaks on what happens their feelings if
it went into playoff and Jan mentioned
well we still have two classical games
it is too early to call Robert what are
the chances of this match actually going
into the playoffs
it's impossible to predict at this point
because we didn't think that dick
lebrand was going to win this game and
he did it's six to six so by the
scoreboard if we just looked at that we
take great chances typically at the
highest level and they draw a lot so we
might see a couple draws a split point
and then we will end our world
championship in tie breaks but I just
don't know what to expect anymore I
don't know if yon will be able to
rebound recover from today's debacle or
of dingley Ren with his Newfound
confidence if he can try to hold
tomorrow and win game 14 there's a lot
that remains to be seen
it's kind of back and forth this kind of
these kind of comebacks this kind of
Chess we haven't seen at the world
championship well Fabi you mentioned you
have to go back in history to the 2006
2006 World Championship match between
Westland topolo and Vladimir kramnik to
think of this level of drama that we're
experiencing at the world championship
between Yan and ding what do you think
is going on what's the reason for that
Fabi
well at this point I really think
tiredness and nerves plays a huge part
and although Yan uh said that it was
still mostly about the chess I think I
think
um was more on the spot uh with his
assessment that it is probably about
nervous in that although the quality was
low
um yeah right now it's it's going to be
a battle of who can hold it together
best
and we can only imagine how tired you
are after after 12 games of
back and forth tough a lot of emotions
especially you know and we know that
emotion uh emotional games where you're
losing or you're winning or there's
those emotional swings that saps a lot
of your nervous energy so they've had to
deal with a lot of that throughout the
match
um multiple times by now
and today is like the culmination of all
of that all that crazy stuff and I think
today we'll be exhausting for both of
them because uh ding you know he he won
but for sure it stopped a lot of his
emotional and mental energy because he
also realized that he was on the verge
of losing and excitement of winning as
well all of that is is definitely an
addition to the stress uh for Jan of
course
yeah I can't imagine how how he feels I
mean it must be completely heartbreaking
um especially as he knows that he was
winning he felt it uh we all we all knew
that he was on the verge of winning that
game and
it just fell fell apart at that super
crucial moment when he was so close to
uh the Finish Line at least in this game
and potentially in the entire match
yeah and I mean I just had a thought
based on what you were saying before
Fabi about this world championship and
how it's so decisive Tanya your question
uh I think this is a rarity right we're
having a world championship we're the
best player in the world is not taking
part and so uh we don't see maybe as
accurate chess as we would if Magnus
Carlsen were playing that's no
disrespect meant towards the players
it's just objective fact that Magnus
Carlson he has been the best player for
a long time now he was the world
champion he decided not to take part so
uh it's been fun it's a roller coaster
ride and I'm happy to be on it but I
think maybe for some out there they're
looking at this match and they're saying
I enjoy the Fighting Chess we're seeing
I like the decisive games but you know
maybe in some ways the world champion
title is a bit diminished without Magnus
Carlsen taking part I'm not sure
taught there but Robert to me this has
been a really emotional day I have to
say the kind of Chess we saw I just felt
like excellent play by both these
players and no matter who you're rooting
for in this world championship match
your team thing or your team Napo it
just feels like today you've got a feel
for Yan it just felt absolutely
heartbreaking to watch him in those last
moments of the game and indeed he's got
a tough task to it ahead of him with two
classical games he has to overcome his
own journey of today he has to overcome
all that happened in the game today not
only thinking about the leveled match
that now means he has to start from
scratch everything that he he did the
big win that he had taking the one point
lead keeping it pretty much till the
very tail end of the match and then
staring at another win and then letting
it slip it's going to be a tough night
for team nepo his task is cut it's not
just about focusing on opening
preparation tomorrow but how important
Fabi will also be the psychological
aspect going into game 13.
yeah I think it's going to be super
important and that's why if I were to
advise Jan and I think that his seconds
will probably advise him similarly in
this way that um keep it under under
control you know
of course Jan can play Super well he can
play at near near perfect chess as we
saw a few games in a row and also for
pretty much the entirety of the game
today playing nearly perfect chess
but you just got to keep your emotions
in check and it cost him very dearly
today but it's still an even match he he
has no reason to despair because he
missed a big chance for sure to to
nearly win the match today but uh it's
still a 50 50 situation
of course it's going to be very tough
but you you kind of want to approach it
just like it's a clean slate right like
it's from game one we have two games
it's a two game match forget about
everything that happened previously and
uh
short match followed by a short tie
break you know it's either of these guys
could be world champion
in a few days I I wouldn't even venture
to Guess Who at this point
[Music]
us for this match it's been amazing
Robert and Fabi calling this out with
you guys you guys have been incredible
breaking down the action that these
world-class players have been bringing
on getting into their minds and calling
it all out so thank you Robert thank you
Fabi we will be back with game 13 Action
chess is beautiful but equally brutal
and that's what we saw today we leave
you with the emotional rollercoaster
that was game 13.
foreign
I want to see him come out fighting not
make a peaceful solid draw he really
needs to throw everything but the
kitchen sink at Yana palmistry today I
have a feeling 1d4 commanding do this do
this for the chat do it for the
commentators eat three oh my goodness he
is playing a quiet line this is uh known
as the Cole right Bishop D7 I see uh
Robert that it's a bad move this is
honestly a great outcome from the
opening for dingley Wren I am very very
shocked by the fact that he played
Bishop B7 and then Bishop G4 feels like
he just gave dig a tempo for free it
looks like Jan's the one who's feeling
the comfort in this position I'm getting
worried for doing here he needs to make
a move and second he needs to show more
confidence in this position sometimes
feels unfair in chess when you're like
wait I thought I made a good move why am
I getting a question mark but this was a
mistake this is a really really great
move from Jana palmchi he played it
quickly he played it confidently and
it's just one of those moves that you
need to make in order to become a world
champion maybe there a bishop takes G6
that should have been played first but
he plays Bishop B8 does yonder probably
and oh my goodness the evaluations where
it went all the way up and dingley runs
favor Queen B7 was ding's Choice he also
doesn't find the best move I have to say
these guys are just fried at this point
like they've stopped calculating what is
F5
oh my gosh we're takes E6 drops are not
the bun third bond that Yan gives up
quickly played handshakes and that is it
E6 on the board the England comes back
in the match we've got a match on our
hands
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]